[Music]
hey what is up guys i'm kim Bhd here and
this is a compilation video of all of
the best set up tours sent to me over
the month of february 2014 and there are
a lot of them as you can probably tell
by the length of this video and my own
set up tour video will be uploaded as a
separate video pretty shortly so
definitely stay tuned for that and hit
that like button if you're excited to
see it but without any further ado this
is the setup tour project
2014 enjoy this first batch of setups
are the desktops the sort of traditional
setups if you will and the time stamps
are below in the description if you want
to skip ahead to another category but
this first category here are the setups
that are built around your traditional
tower PC this is my man cave this has
all my toes in it basically we've got
some drawers with bags separating out
different connectors and things the
speakers are angled slightly obscurely
to stop cross the stereo some cheap
headphones nice cheap keep on maths but
both being excellent the duct really
handily sits my Nexus 7 and my HTC One
which is great I have a female USB
coming up from the PC and this TV is
used to projects recipe like etc there's
my webcam which is awesome my microphone
hey guys Esper Don here I'd like to
thank mkbhd for making this setup tour
project possible so here's my setup
thing a most proud of is my DVI switch
that I can use with both my computer and
my now aging ps3
[Music]
hey guys this is my setup and over here
we have a Canon printer scanner with my
netbook for school which is a Dell
Latitude series and behind it is a
Seagate external hard drive over here
running the show is a HP XW 4600
workstation which runs Windows 7 and Mac
OS 10 down here we got my ipod 4th
generation and here's my LG monitor with
full logitech surround sound
what's up world this is a quick glimpse
of my studio YT generation first off is
my iMac right here bowl speakers my HP
and Asus laptops my cat you 37
microphone my Numark Mixtrack controller
a wall of posters my v-moda crossfades
LP and my ear beat too bad can show you
everything but thanks for watching come
on guys take a look at my desktop and my
workflow setup the first thing you'll
see is the MacBook Pro which I have tied
into my hackintosh it helps me render
and crunch through the video have the
Focusrite interface the Asus IPS 27-inch
monitor of course with my studio
monitors that you see there on the side
for the sound one of the next things I
wanna highlight is my hackintosh one
thing I love about my hackintosh
still old-school you're able to burn
blu-ray and regular DVDs and then the
biggest focus point which is my camera
which is the Canon EOS m mirrorless DSLR
camera that shoots 14 ATP video I love
this camera because it gives me the
video quality of a SLR just in a smaller
point to shoot form factor
[Music]
what up guys welcome to the wide shot of
my PC setup this is a 27-inch 1440p
monitor by Dell smaller 22 inch one and
I also have my TV hooked up to the PC
the Nexus 7 and my Galaxy Note but I
really want to show you my son monitors
the atom 8 3 X together with the
Focusrite Saffire pro 24 interface most
amazing sound you will ever get out of
your PC what is going on everybody
hello mkbhd fans this is my setup I got
Moroccan here my mechanical backlit
keyboard my 1080p monitors surround
sound speaker systems wireless
headphones and my pride and joy custom
build PC that tubing peace out hey mkbhd
this is my setup I'll start with my iMac
I really do like it because I could use
it for work in place since it's Windows
and Mac here's some shots of some other
stuff I have in my desk thanks so much
for taking a look at my workstation
you
hey guys welcome to my setup project
here I have my desk custom PC two
monitors 27 inch and 24 with a MacBook
Air
iPad holder on the wall here I've got
some little collectibles as well as
Google glass and Nexus wireless charger
the top monitor is mounted with a desk
mount that hangs over the 27-inch
alright thanks guys this is my setup for
the setup tour 2014 project on mkbhd s
channel on the wall we have memorabilia
from my past childhood posters the
desktop computer that is everything is
run on and of course Audio Technica m50
s sitting up there and the quick-fire CX
storm keyboard what's up mkbhd fan so
this is my desk so over here we've got
the iPhone 4s the iPad air apple
wireless keyboard the Mac Pro 13 inch
and the iPad Mini we can't forget about
the beast so right here the 27-inch iMac
this is the late 2012 model no one think
that makes my desk unique are the
speakers that mkb she reviewed a while
back and that's why I'm watching him now
enough above I've Emir just to see who's
coming in coming up so that's my desk
and thank you for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so this is my new setup a week ago I
built my first PC and this is the result
a dual monitor setup and an old HP
laptop on the other side of my desk
while I do my homework my favorite part
is his speaker set no I'm joking
I really have to replace them I like
these monitors the most from the algae
IPs flatten series they have a really
thin edge and a great design my computer
is a piece of a machine and really
powerful what's up everyone here's a
quick video of my work slash PlayStation
starting from the left there's an M
audio mini keyboard Astro a40 headset a
few Xbox controllers and a Sony PSP TV
send it on my desk is an Xbox one Xbox
360 scuf controller and Elgato Game
Capture HD on the right side of the desk
is a 27-inch imac a 13-inch MacBook a
Wacom tablet an iPad and three external
hard drives for storage thanks for
watching hey what it took got its blades
in it and today I'm going to show you my
new set at all so here at my left its my
xbox 360 slim we should don't play
anymore okay
here I have my special edition white X
plus 360 controller next I have my Apple
kick white cable here my Apple Mouse and
finally my iMac May 2012 version so I've
already just start to youtube and it's
my first ever video and hopefully in the
future our progress peace hey what's up
mkbhd found this boost HD here and this
is a very quick tour of my setup so I
used two 22 inch LED monitors at the
left monitor also doubles up as my
gaming monitor for my ps3 this is all
powered by AMD custom built PC as well
as my Dell Optiplex
office PC I'll start my TV to the left
the setup and below that I have my retro
consoles my Gamecube my xbox my ps2 HD
PVR and my ps3 thank you for watching
[Music]
to me simplicity is the most important
factor when creating a set up
[Music]
you
[Music]
hi my name is Michelle and this is my
workstation I am currently a fashion
design student and I'm always on the go
so as you can tell I have far too many
tablets for one person but they all have
a specific use for me I do like to play
video games at times because I do get
stressed out as many other students do
so when that does happen I just turn
around and I can utilize my xbox 360 or
my xbox one hi everyone I'm Connor Emily
and this is my very own music production
video editing a 3d animation and
programming workstation on my desk we've
got my computer which is running Linux
right now but also runs the last 10 and
Windows and that's what all my
peripherals and then on the Left we've
got my 15 inch retina MacBook Pro
however my ear part of this whole setup
is on the other side of the room where
I've got two or more huts up to
raspberry PI's playing slideshows this
means that if I want to change what
they're playing all I have to do is get
out my trusty meadow X looks where my
picture is pick an album and boom I've
got a new slideshow playing just like
that anyway that's about it so thanks
for watching
all right so that's my workstation right
there I have a half 9:32 full tower it's
actually very good for cooling and
l-shaped this which is actually very
nice I like the actual quality of it and
then going up to this I have a still
series keyboard razor mouse still series
gamepad little mouse pad right there my
bad then I have speakers that are
actually facing me so I can get a nice
quality when I'm gaming I have a Yeti
microphone and a 23 inch Acer monitor if
I'm not mistaken now the main highlight
this whole thing is that my computer is
able to boot windows 7 and Mavericks so
I can do you might be dug in
commentaries and edit my videos hey
what's up guys this is Bill from going
with your tech and this is a quick room
tour so I have two that's one for
filming and the other is where I do my
video editing so on the Left I have
MacBook Pro have a blue Yeti and iMac a
24 inch samsung Display and I've had
many and a surface pro the main
headphones I use is the audio technica
ath m50 I also use the Apple wireless
keyboard and Magic Mouse for gaming I
used a mad catz rat 3 this is my custom
PC duel 10 if he monitors different
manufacturers I really care I got water
yeah stay hydrated
got a nice fan controller in there and
my wireless adapter cables on cables
just a mess Logitech G 510 keyboard pity
DS hoodies
I'm also movie junkie so he's my laptop
of portable power and entertainment and
yeah that's really it
hey it's Jeff and this is my work space
for the mkbhd 2014 set up tour project
and as you can see I have a simple
layout keyboard mouse monitor computer
and a Bose and the main reason behind
this is because I use this work area for
playing video games doing homework and
watching tech videos and I'm gonna
highlight my custom rig with the windows
2000 and no Pentium sticker and I'm
actually not using either of those I'm
using Windows 8 and I've been into i7
4770k thank you for watching peace hey
guys bo HD here and this is my setup
tour underneath I've got my custom-built
PC that handles all of my video editing
needs I've got two 23 inch full HD
Samsung monitors up top sitting right
next to my Nexus wireless charger
wireless mouse and wireless keyboard
moving on over to the left of my desk
you'll find my LG g2 my trusty Nexus 7
along with my review unit of the LG G
pad Google Play edition next to that is
my sony vaio fit 15 laptop that I can
use to edit while on the go and then one
of the most unique things about my
workspace is this custom built poster
that I made for my old tech boxes hello
mkbhd fans my name is helical Hill from
hey try utilities and today I'm gonna
quickly show you my desk setup as you
can see I have a dual monitor serve on a
simple unobtrusive desk I have done XPS
8500 dual booting Windows 8 pro and OS
10 mavericks I think my favorite thing
on this desk is the dual monitors
because helps me greatly when
programming I hope you enjoyed the rest
of the great quantum produced by marques
but other than that I'll see you later
thanks for listening bye hey everyone
I'm John Aki advise UK and this is my
setup so in front of you you can see my
Samsung 23 inch 1080p monitor and I
decided that I have to logitech said
three to three speakers in front of that
I've got my Logitech performance MX
Mouse and my red and black Corsair
Vengeance k70 keyboard I've also got a
13-inch 2013 MacBook Air and the Beast
that was providing all that power is my
custom-built gaming PC
hey guys it's Nick from ID Apple and
this is my setup first off my I have my
blue Yeti microphone with a pop pop
filter by blue next I have my bose
companion 2 series 3 speakers
apple wireless keyboard and trackpad
anchor for point USB 3 hub v-moda
crossfade m100 headphones and the two
27-inch 2013 imac hey everybody i'm on a
review of my setup as if you wants a
minimalistic on the white table there's
only little a 2013 27-inch imac and the
quite awesome looking low gtex set 5 v
free stereo speakers all the cable
management is down under the table
nothing spectacular here and yeah that's
pretty much it peace out a worth of guys
my name is Tim and today I have my
submission for setup to project 2014 and
I have the most basic setup so this is
my iPad Mini
my xbox 360 a control on a control on a
custom stand by me which I have videos
as well my full speakers monitor Razer
colitis [ __ ] gaming mouse the Razer
DeathAdder a controller my 4 point 2
channel speakers and excuse you betta
beat you with a custom-made stand by me
and a phone go pro so I hope I get
selected yeah peace out what's up guys
Jesse film 17 and here's my setup to her
project 2014 to start off I have a
27-inch late 2012 iMac with 16 gigabytes
of ddr3 RAM and I have to a sir monitors
one on each side of my main IMAX screen
some other things on my desk are an iPad
2 beats headphones a GoPro here through
plus Silver Edition a Jawbone Jambox in
for my daily driver
I had the galaxy No
what's up mkbhd and YouTube this is
Jerry Neutron and what you are looking
at here is my budget workstation build
now everything here was purchased with a
specific budget in mind and focusing on
getting the best bang for your buck and
I spent a lot of time here gaming video
editing and web designing so it's really
important that I finished off my build
with a sweet mini-fridge
this is my desk subtle I have a course a
gaming rig down the bottom audio
technica ath every 50 headphones
SteelSeries peripherals a loose monitors
and a 13-inch MacBook Pro all of this is
sitting on a custom desk that I had
built welcome to my brief setup tour
video I'm using a custom gaming / video
editing PC I built back in early 2013
with my computer I used my Logitech G
19's backlit keyboard I also have a pair
of inexpensive studio monitors with
great sound quality and they are the
m-audio AV 40s for listening to music I
use my Logitech UE 9000 Bluetooth
headphones what I like about my setup is
actually the desk itself the overall
size of it and the fact that I can
adjust the height is quite useful what's
up guys here's my setup we'll start off
with the Xbox you see that's connected
to my 32 inch TV use my Logitech c920
ler Airport extreme with a portable hard
drive blue Yeti with that 50 s on top
she doesn't love an iMac with a second
display and all of this is on a custom
built dusk welcome to my setup which
includes a pair of yamaha HS 80s a late
2013 Mac Pro connected to a dell you
2711 display with a rode procaster mic
hanging in front of it along the back
edge I have a 6 foot strip of Philips
hue LED lights and I'm running all of my
audio for this setup through a focus
right Forte I prefer to use Sony v6
headphones and I have them resting on a
just mobile headphone stand and to keep
my cables nice and tidy I'm using a blue
lounge cable box overall I like to keep
my setup simple and clean this is my
main editing setup
I have a custom-built hackintosh on the
bottom along with two 23 inch Apple
cinema HD displays that are running off
of that I have my 15 inch Retina Display
MacBook Pro and all my hard drives down
there hi marques here is my video entry
for the 2014 set of tour in the
background you can spark my ps3 my main
display is Adele you 2412
Lexx to the keyboard on my ATH m50
headphones and at2020 studio condenser
mic the PC case is housing two hard
drives an SSD and IM d GPU cooled with a
jellied aftermarket cooler and an intel
cpu which is kept cool and quiet by a
Noctua
and HD 14 a little sneak peak of my
Logitech G 25 racing video to end the
video and that's all thanks for watching
everyone this is Matt d and welcome to
my very quick setup tour first off my
blue digital spark microphone some
memory card readers my Belkin energy
monitor my logitech g930 headset and z
550 sound system my wireless xbox360
controller and I've had two HDMI adapter
in DisplayPort to HDMI adapter my
15-inch MacBook Pro on the right there
my iPad Mini retina my HTC One phone and
across my desk is - 24 inch Samsung
monitors the showcase in my setup is my
55 inch samsung LED TV that's mounted to
my wall and down below is my custom
built PC with an APC UPS thanks everyone
for watching what's up guys meta trucks
here and this is my setup tour for the
mkbhd 2014 setup tour compilation
starting from the right we have a CD
shelf wireless HP printer my mobile
devices Asus memo pad iPad 3 2011
MacBook Pro Xbox 360 dual monitor setup
monoprice 2560 by 1440 on the left and
insignia 1080p on the right this is my
custom build hackintosh i7 16 gigs ram
dual SSDs booting both OS X and Windows
8 and this has been a quick look at my
setup tour I hope you guys like it
thanks peace out hey what's up guys is
this mini tough and this is my current
setup I've been adding lots of pieces
over the years and this is finally where
it's gotten to down below it's all
powered by
custom PC which also doubles as a
hackintosh when I needed to for audio
I'm using my audio technica ath and 50s
as well as my blue yeti stereo
microphone what I like most about my
setup is the three monitors that I have
it makes multitasking and brewery's it
means I can get a lot done at once well
that's my setup thanks for watching
peace hey Marcus this is my setup what's
special about this setup is that it's a
hybrid between a gaming and the music
rig all held together by my scarlett 2i2
I'm actually going to New York next week
so my setup is going to be a bit
different after that I'm rocking the
Logitech G 710 plus eraser Abbas's and
Calathes
and the pair of Siberia v2 s thank you
for watching hello guys so from the left
we have the h2 n from zoom the iPad air
32 gives audio technica at2020 iPhone 5s
Harman Kardon some speakers let cinema
display 27 inches with the Logitech c920
Apple keyboard Logitech MX revolution
Mouse MacBook Pro late 2011 quad-core
and Mac Mac Pro late 2015 EXA core thank
you for watching what up guys feel
fulfilled check this is my desk tour I
got the Apple Mouse another Mouse the
Pro Tools keyboard the mid 2010 MacBook
Pro 21 inch 2011 iMac I got a Prius
honest - preamp focus right interface
Nexus 5 Nexus 10 - JBL speakers rode
nt1-a for the mic and some Sennheiser
headphones and that's it I'm out
hey guys it's Mason and this is my setup
I currently have two 1080p monitors
loggy tech speakers with a subwoofer a
razer Deathstalker keyboard a log e tech
mouse and a SteelSeries mouse pad
I also have a Nexus 7 2013 Audio
Technica headphones in a white Xbox 360
the main focus of my setup is my custom
build PC with a quad-core i7 processor
4.4 gigahertz and the GTX 780 lightning
thank you for checking out my setup and
a big thanks to mkbhd for the
opportunity to share hello guys and
welcome to my setup tour so to start out
I have my Asus monitor my custom built
PC my razor-like cosas keyboard and
razer deathadder mouse with a custom
bioshock infinite mouse pad a USB hub
blu-ray reader writer and then a really
interesting part is my two monitors one
under to save space so I can have
multiple mkbhd Rosewill headset with
vibration and then some generic
honey-nut O's
hello wooden how is everyone doing my
name is potato puppet and this is my
desk to her slash gaming setup I have a
triple monitor setup with a PC desktop
I'm not much of a Mac fanboy and I've
got an Xbox 360 and my 5.1 surround
sound speakers I hope you enjoyed
you
sup guys here's my entry before the set
up solar project 2014 there's my ps4 my
32 inch HDTV running a Windows 8.1
there's my white Logitech Keyboard
Wolverine guarding my custom-made PC I
built it myself has a quad-core
processor 8 gigs of ram and the msi r7
260x there we go thanks for watching
guys
hey guys to meet all my working gaming
setup he could see my sony playstation 4
my LG 40 sections TV my jewel 24 inch LG
monitors the Microsoft killer Mouse and
iPad 4th generation Buy and here is all
my cables for the computer my
custom-built hackintosh under there you
can see the power Mac the printer the
subwoofer and the mixer to the left and
above the setup is my BenQ 3d projector
hello this is my setup so uh basics pets
my computer r r9 270x and an AMD 6300
got two monitors my Asus 24-inch and
then my Apple Cinema Display 23 inch
here's some of my things racer Goliath
Apple keyboard and Logitech mouse thanks
hey guys this is my setup tour right
here I have my Sony speakers my 23 inch
Acer monitor Coolermaster keyboard
turtlebeach x12 headset in this case
right here the big showcase is Anna
Peavy ax X trooper in green and I built
this pc very recently
thanks for looking guys what's up guys
this is Michael I'm gonna give you guys
a quick tour of my desk here we got my
Fender Stratocaster guitar some
miscellaneous headphones including my V
motocross for you to LPS we have an iPod
Nano fourth generation Samsung Galaxy
Nexus the Nexus 7 my Lenovo laptop which
is my main computer which is hooked up
to this 22 inch AOC monitor my two
keyboards two mice and the secondary
Dell computer down there hey guys this
is tech tester HD here and today I will
show you my setup heinous the apple
smart case and deca by Hamburg for the
iPad air here is my iPad for my videos
only speaker of my sound system my
monitors from Samsung my iPhone 4 in the
small brick stock the mobi magic charger
my Mac Mini late 2012 with an SSD and
four gigabyte RAM and here is my
microphone the t1s C hundred forty
thanks for watching and have fun with
the other videos
[Music]
[Music]
hey what is up everyone this is Sarepta
from tech square and this is my
submission to the mkbhd set up your
project now my desk is dominated by a
high end maxed out 2012 Mac Mini along
with my pride and joy that's my dual
monitor setup moving a bit right and you
will find a Windows computer with a
decent specs and that makes a perfect
atmosphere for both of the operating
systems to breed up anyway guys that's
been it and I hope you guys enjoyed my
setup
alright mkbhd viewers here's a little
tour of my desk got my little heartless
collection I'm starting up my nametag
for working at Gamestop some of my blue
snowball my speakers my Mac Mini and my
dream car the Lamborghini Aventador keep
that there's a reminder some monster
cans my mustang cat max box my TV and
what is up guys it's on a tech here with
a quick 30 second entry for mkbhd setup
tour project my desk is pretty simple
but the cool thing is that everything
here costs only about 600 bucks all of
the controllers are 60 bucks the
logitech speakers were only 10 my 22
inch monitor with 65 bucks to use the
low cam was actually a gift for my
parents my pc itself with all the
components was only about 420 dollars I
bought my mouse for $2 at a flea market
and my keyboard was $25 at OfficeMax
my mouse pad was actually made by me and
my desk was $25 on Craigslist so that's
my setup and I hope you guys enjoyed
hello marques so running the show is a
2012 Mac Mini with fully loaded 16
gigabytes of RAM and it's a really good
frediting a lot of my components such as
the keyboard and mouse are wireless so
when you're sitting at the desk it
appears that there's almost no cables
which is pretty awesome for cable
management because it was a lot of
really cost conservative while buying
this set up the total cost comes in
around $1,100 so I can either have you
know the latest MacBook Air or this
entire set up so which one would you
decide
[Music]
hey what's going on Kay PhD the quick
tour my set up or you see over top there
I have a few pictures posters on the
wall I my headphones which are mounted
for easy removal hi my imac for studies
my ipad for travels my custom-built
gaming pc with dual samsung 23 inch
monitors gaming keyboard gaming mouse
also over here's my sucky 4k display TV
50-inch have a nice one hey everybody
welcome to my setup now as you can see
everything has a black-and-white theme
with a blue globe and also everything's
wireless so it's easy to use and classy
looking now the great part about having
a white desk is being able to take notes
on it like over here and this setup
would not be complete without the
beating heart of it my home built
hackintosh pro toady dumped HD here time
for setup to her let's do this IKEA
fretted desk yeah it's like here and
it's awesome sexy fractal are four
anchor 8000 dpi mouse with Logitech g71
O+ keyboard get to know player Xbox 360
then an AVR X 500 amps celestion f-35c
center speaker Celestion 3 yeah
made in England baby what's that another
Celestion oh look another Celestia oh
look and another Celestia 5.1 in this
setup baby then an ahd 2000 modeled with
d5000 cup Lorton audio pads d7000 cable
damn yeah that's right toy eiffel sub
dan that's sexy PC master-race
Logitech my time to tell myself how much
I've been gaming much love hey what's up
guys so this is my brother's gaming ring
the Alienware Aurora r3 from 2012 he
also uses the quote-unquote mkbhd studio
speakers along with a 23 inch HP monitor
and he also has a turtle beach headset
and he uses a nexus 4 as its daily
driver and for portable gaming he uses
the TS XL
hey what's up guys for my setup I'm
using a late 2011 Mac Mini with 16 gigs
of RAM and an SSD along with a 23 inch
monitor from HP and for audio I use the
blue Yeti microphone I also have a
standard keyboard and mouse and my main
phone is the all-black 32 gig Nexus 5 as
you guys can probably see I only keep 6
items on my desk for that clean look and
like Leonardo da Vinci once said
simplicity is the ultimate
sophistication
what's going on YouTube my name is Mons
and this is my setup to her for mkbhd
right here we got my iPad air along with
my iPhone 5s and customized moto X right
here we have my late 2013 iMac with my
gaming keyboard and mouse with the BenQ
gaming monitor and my custom-built
gaming PC with Xbox 360 down there right
over here is my desk for school which is
my 2012 retina MacBook Pro a few
headphones and some studio monitors and
my AKG perception 420 mic there it is
thanks to marques for the opportunity
for this video see you what's going on
everyone in Travers consumer and here's
a quick look at my death setup I'm using
dual monitors with an iMac and
PlayStation 3d display I use a pretty
large desk to do most of my recording
and work and to the side of my desk is
my section of portables including
handheld gaming systems tablets and
phones what makes my setup unique is
this hanging cabinet with most of my
gaming consoles that are all connected
to my Playstation display as well as my
collection of headphones above them this
setup is designed to be the perfect work
and play environment hey what's up guys
and welcome to my set of tour for
peripherals I'm using the Apple wireless
keyboard and wireless trackpad as well
as this Kensington bluetooth wireless
mouse my monitor is a 24 inch full HD
1080p display made by Dell and the most
important part of my setup is probably
my audio as you can see I have two
stereo monitors made by M audio this
awesome audio interface and also the
legendary audio technica ath M 50s for
mind or headphones plus I have this blue
USB microphone for all my recordings
here's my network router cables more
cables and the beast which powers at all
is my 2014 hackintosh with an i7 4770k
on the inside thank you guys for
watching
[Music]
[Music]
hi my name is Janice and in this video
I'm going to make you a quick tour of my
setup as you can see I use two displays
which is very classic and also a flex 14
but of course the most important point
is configuration and as you can see I
got a full custom water-cooled build
with a black and white theme and I used
a lot of a quwata blocks equipment I use
a t-bone microphone for the audio
recording and I also have my pebble
smartwatch near to me when I work hey
guys is my office I've got some IKEA
furniture with a kitchen counter worktop
along the whole top that makes a nice
desk main machines a Mac Mini ad for
work gaming machines in a different room
underneath the desk also got tiresome
IKEA furniture for storage paper and
toner bits and pieces on the back or
another but a custom wood there for a
workbench with some tubs underneath for
easy access and on the back there I've
got some old server hard drives that
show off the LEDs what's up everyone my
name is Thomas and this is the my setup
tour video 4d mkbhd channel so without a
further deal let's get started starting
from the left my 2010 unibody MacBook
followed by my third gen iPad my
secondary monitor has been QFP to 0 to W
and my primary monitor as Dell as 20 to
40 T which is a 10-point multi-touch
monitor moving on further we can see my
razer kraken headphone my wireless
printer powering this whole setup is my
custom built computer which runs both
Windows and OS 10 mavericks thank you
for watching my setup and a huge shout
out to mkbhd for making this video
possible
this is my setup starting from the left
over here we got a bunch of
miscellaneous crap and simple the nice
speakers and a cheap digital amp 27-inch
monoprice monitor not the best louder
but higher resolution is definitely nice
got a tower in the back and 6a psyche
watching over everything
hey guys it's Alex err and today I'll be
giving you a quick tour over my setup so
overall I would say that my setup is
very simple and works best for me and
all that I do and I always like to have
a clean workspace starting off I have my
eel ooh major type are a gaming mouse
next I have my razor like close a
keyboard and also I have my Sennheiser
HD - a - over the head earphones one
special thing I would say about my setup
would be made custom PC it's pretty much
my pride and joy in the powerhouse to
get whatever I need to do done so thanks
for watching my setup tour for 2014 and
hope you like this video hello everybody
this is my setup for the setup your
project 2014 right here I have my school
provided Chromebook this is covering and
because as it's important information
that I'm one of the people to see it has
a sticker there I have my 20 inch
monitor that I will be soon and placing
with a matching 1080p 24-inch ACS
monitor right there and um I think my
favorite part of my setup is the Eclipse
pro media 2.1 speakers with the sub
right there thanks for watching guys
[Music]
what's up marques Austin here and first
off big congrats on reaching 1 million
subscribers here on YouTube it's a big
feat not only for you but for the tech
community in general so here is my setup
tour as you can see it's kind of similar
to yours but I went for more of a black
and white theme here I have some studio
monitors my dell ultrasharp 27-inch
monitor mechanical keyboard and my
custom built video editing machine that
I did a series on on the channel so on
thank you for featuring my video in your
set of tour and I can't wait to see the
rest of them thanks for watching guys
and enjoy the rest of the videos pretty
from Laos in Southeast Asia everybody
here's my setup first off you have a
MacBook Pro 15 inch Galaxy mega 6.3 inch
a 27-inch Apple full-size keyboard
Samsung 21 inch gold speaker ATH and 50
and 1820 35 down here we have hackintosh
custom built we have something for as
well as the Focusrite audio interface
docu on top we have the 650d camera and
60 as well as the nylons 2070 200 and
this is pretty much it guys
hello everybody welcome to my setup so
here you can see I have the KRK Rokit
AIDS and if we go over here I have the
hi-fi man 8400 headphones and those are
both hooked up right here to the
Focusrite - I - and my computer over
here has an i7 960 and a GTX 760 hey
guys I'm Brian and this is my setup to
her now because I have such a small room
I don't have a smaller place my setup I
saw my possible because of my core desk
my PC is a custom-built CyberPower PC so
only started PC for now but I'm giving
it more updates as time progresses
otherwise have a 2.1 Altec Lansing
speakers system with subwoofer and
turtlebeach extroverts that my mother is
in the Zeus twenty three point six inch
1080p full HD monitor it just barely
fits on my small desk my phone is a
samsung galaxy s3 and that small control
to its left is able to control the
lights and fan in my room comes in handy
my keyboard MLS aren't anything special
they came with a computer but I kept
them because of the rhythm but look as
you may have noticed already I have a
thing for her - black just
lose someone I know well guys just wraps
up my setup to work thank you hey there
my name is Brian Hempstead and this is
my setup tour 2014 oh this is awkward
well we got I'll just get this guy all
the way here this is my main play slash
workstation as you can see I've taken a
lot of inspiration from your videos
[Music]
hey guys here's my setup for mkbhd I'm
left I have my Nexus 10 on a stand in
the center I have two HP monitors 123
inch 121 inch both 1080p running Windows
8.1 and the favorite part about this is
my custom build PC which has an 8 core
AMD processor and 8 gigs of RAM my name
is Bryce and here is my setup what is
unique about my setup is that my entire
workspace is where it falls it used to
be I have a custom computer I built two
24h monitors a blue Yeti and of course
audio technica ath 150s
my mobile devices are the Nexus 4 and
third generation iPad for school I also
have various other devices and
accessories thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
my name is Sarah and this is my video
response to mkbhd setup to a project
2014 pretty simple sauce with an iMac
2013 there's a Magic Mouse right here
don't know it's magic MacBook Pro right
here
and finally the keyboard so pretty
simple here it is as a white view thanks
for watching
hey what's up guys just wanted to give
you a quick glimpse of my workspace area
here first thing you'll notice is my
Stay Puft they're holding my two dual
monitors which is connected to my
custom-built computer right down there
and of course my love for Android
continues to be right here I have a
nexus 7 2013 model and will stroll over
here I have a nexus 7 2012 Nexus 4 razor
em over here would be my printer area
along with the phone that I'm currently
recording on which is a note 3 recording
in a 4k resolution hi guys welcome to my
desktop setup and it's a Mac Mini with
Apple display and sporting a
stormtrooper Nexus 5 mobile phone and I
do prefer a pin to an actual Mouse
itself I've got a Nikon d80 camera and a
beats box portable which I have that
connected up to my Mac and of course
there's Milton from outer space with my
headphones massive old printer with my
Mac Mini hard drives and a DSL modems
that's all tucked aside to make it look
a clean and neat table and of course
what's an Android user without a whole
heap of Android so hope you enjoy guys
tease hello everyone this is my setup
for my mouse I have a Logitech g600 2
for my headphones I have a sizer 5 5/8
for my keyboard I have a gas keyboard
with cherry MX blue switches for my
sound I have a Pheo e 10 deck and my PC
is how is in a cuba technique cube all
aluminum case it is fairly unique
because it is really small you can see
my hand for comparison and the rest of
the setup so yeah and it's pretty much
my entire setup hey what's going on
mkbhd so this is my desktop tour so if
you can't tell I called it semi-ghetto
because my room is basically kind of
cabin themed yeah I don't know I'm not a
huge fan of cabins anyways I just I
don't know um but this is my desktop
tour now I'm gonna be covering my
desktop or my computer pretty quickly
but I thought I'd just go over some
things I got my 1080p monitor here my
these are actually really good speakers
I don't even I don't know what they're
called but pretty good for I think
they're like 30 bucks and some of the
best speakers I've heard not post
quality or anything uh my wireless
keyboard and mouse set my gaming headset
because I am kind of a gamer I'm only 15
though and then finally my desktop now
the reason I'm gonna be talking about my
desktop really quick is because I
actually built it I just think that's a
little special and I also I also did
just to save some money but that's
pretty much how the point but yeah other
than some drawers and stuff that's
basically my desktop tuara thanks for
watching as you say base hey guys here's
my quick set-up tour video as you can
see it's really clean and simple kick it
off
I got an Apple iMac 27-inch latest model
with top-of-the-line specs we've got a
set of hard drives for backup Apple
Magic Mouse wireless keyboard got a
couple of flash drives and SD cards off
to the left you'll see my certain will
take black X hard drive dock which holds
my crucial one terabyte of solid-state
drive that's about it over now
hi folks is my contribution to mkbhd set
up - I've got a 23 inch Philips money -
look - my 21 inch iMac crudités - you're
monitoring energy Oh technica ath m-52
listen to palma music for school I use
my SC 720 Chromebook and its massive 7
hours battery I can carry my HTC One
everywhere with its insecured you are
pro shine kids
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
LG 29 inch widescreen monitor using
moderate x21 Sakura audio and a Canon
t3i to record video my speakers surround
sound Sony audio system in the corner 24
inch Samsung TV Bose over the ear
headphones with Samsung Galaxy s3 a
laptop lenovo core i7 third gen with
nvidia geforce 630 m some ipods and a
third gen iPad slim ps2 of the Sega
second gen on top and what got my ps3
mounted to the wall my dad at her 2013
edition gotta say my favorite things my
monitor and my LEDs welcome to my desk
set up for my keyboard I'm using a
corsair k70 keyboard with red switches
and a basic Mouse
my main monitor is a 22 inch LG and I
used that zoom h1 for voiceovers or
whatnot I'm also using a 20 inch Dell
both of those are 16 by 10 there are my
computer specs and here's my custom PC I
built last September
one unique thing about my desk is that
there are no cables visible underneath
hey guys this is my set up tour starting
off of my desktop off to the side I'll
move over it to my m50 headphones
removable Jack my phone my dual monitors
both 20-inch 1600 by 900 my bluetooth
keyboard wireless mouse my 5.1 surround
system with my sub and guitar off to the
side and my desk does extend out pretty
far as you can see for more room to do
homework and such so this has been my
set up tour thanks to you and KB HD
welcome everybody to general elements
desk tour so down here you got my
custom-built desktop which is hooked up
to the 32 inch TV up here with Windows 8
over here on my surface pro my surface
RT and custom-designed mousepad my xbox
360 ps3 and my monster headphones and
then you got my turtle beach's over here
for gaming down here you've got my
mini-fridge got to keep those drinks
cold and then my camera for photography
up here you got my watch collection my
movie and game collection
[Music]
hey what's going on guys it's show here
and this is my desk set up basically I
have my custom-built PC which I build
around a year and a half ago and I
really keep my desk clean so I have a
few essentials such as my microphone my
Nexus 7 my Nexus 4 and my pebble
smartwatch when I'm done using it at the
end of the day hope you all enjoyed and
thank you for the opportunity hey guys
my name is Jordan young this is my setup
I hope you guys enjoy here's my Samsung
27 inch 1080p display my LG 17 inch 720p
display my creative Giga works t40
series 2 stereo speaker system my Samson
co1 a Dalek to guard on my computer
jelly beans of course sonic screwdriver
boom Omar is thank you guys for watching
hope you enjoyed so this is my setup its
gaming setup you know I just got 24-inch
monitor from Asus I've just got a JK
keyboard right now my friend because
I've actually paid for this all by
myself that's why I still had these
Beats headphones I'm trying to save up
for a new set of headphones with you
keyboard but this is my sister we've got
a course I pull her in there it's pretty
good I can't really
he expects because this is it hey
marques my name k shopping here's my
setup so down here I have a custom-built
PC with these specs up here connected to
my PC or two monitors my iPad and my
phone here I also have a set of low-end
speakers but here are parent pose 82's
that I usually use for my audio needs
and the main thing I want to showcase in
my tours is makeshift microphone stand
all it took was a violin stand anything
that resembles abroad from a baseball
bat which is what I used and three
rubber bands I also use the Destin that
came with the microphone to hold it in
place
here's one last shot of my setup and oh
yeah healthy cereal choices marques
everyone's Luke and this is my
submission for the 2014 set up tour
project you have the two monitor
displays once a 27 inch 1/2 22 inch they
both feature an adequate amount of
rainmeter plugins as peripherals I have
the Razer DeathAdder Black Widow and the
black shark headphones hung onto my desk
by a capo there's your headphone hack of
the day piles of a logitech f7 10 game
net to end that all off I have my
coca-cola themed mini-fridge my loot
crate's and my council's thanks for
watching guys stay tuned
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi I'm Gabe HT and welcome to my setup
to her starting over here on the Left we
have my quadcopter with GoPro over here
we have my Acer Aspire v5 notebook here
in the middle we have my Nexus 5 and
24-inch monitor with speakers and over
here on the right is my custom-built
hackintosh pro hope you enjoyed the
video thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
how's we goin everybody my name is Matt
from MS Tech and this is my setup in 30
seconds to fit the time limit I'm gonna
mention the highlights and then use text
for everything else those highlights are
my audio setup and my peripherals my
audio setup consists of the bayer
dynamic DT 770 headphones the Theo e 10
amp and the editor skis sl150 microphone
for peripherals I use a Logitech g600 2
mouse customized CM quick fire rapid
keyboard and the Razer Nostromo paired
with a couple of Asus 1080p monitors I
end up with a pretty good-looking desk
overall hey guys this is my setup so
we'll get right to it I have my HP Envy
120 printer my Dell XPS 8700 desktop
along with them awesome 27-inch monitor
and my personal favorite my Logitech
z520 32.1 speakers and we always have an
iPad on the side just for looking up
stuff alright thanks guys
hi YouTube welcome to my setup this is
my triple monitor setup it's my computer
running i7 and you take 780 there's my
headphones and that's smart cast they're
all on the screen that's my assist we
use a tablet and finally this is my home
theater setup 9 a 4-inch screen 7.1
surround sound ok
this is my setup most of the things you
can see on my desk are connected to my
custom-built 8-core PC some interesting
things about my setup are my Razer
Taipan Mouse which has cool lights and
my monitors the 144 Hertz 24-inch a sous
monitor and my playstation TV which is
using my blue sparks wooden case as it
stand hey guys this is a budget in space
friendly set up that can fin your
bedroom all the items here is going to
be headphones and Mac that can all be
found for under $1500 first we have a
new base model iMac with a pair of beat
solo HDS and v-moda m100 sitting on top
of it then we have a full HD 27-inch
monitor under $100 that gets better
gaming performance because of the Lord
pixel density honor that we have a 2013
MacBook Air and a Apple and Microsoft
wireless keyboard and mouse here we have
an old hackintosh laptop being used as a
media center with my iPod and decent
sounding 150 watt stereo system want to
give special thanks to mkbhd for let me
show my setup tour this is Rick lavell
and I talk to you guys later
you
he is a 2012 and 2013 MacBook Pro 15
point 4 inch display I've got the
Thunderbolt Display Mac Mini as well
with the upgrades inside blue Yeti for
commentary use an iPad Mini on the desk
there Retina display got the keyboard
mouse and trackpad time capsule for my
connection extra cable down there to
plug into the Mac when I'm gaming or
streaming to Xbox one I've had air to
check the stream push everything to
Apple TV using airport extreme 6th gen
to a Samsung 3d LED 240 Hertz TV what's
up YouTube is selling it and welcome to
my entry for mkbhd 30 second test or my
main work area has 2 23 inch 1080p LCD
monitors connected to Allah volt at best
and we've articulated arms now this is
great because he enables me to have more
desk area for my study I have a late
2012 Mac Mini with the eyes 7 processor
and 4 gigabyte of RAM power in place my
monitors and Xbox 360 on the left to lay
back kick my shoes off and enjoy some
late night gaming sessions hey guys this
is my set up tour I've got clips
earphones Audio Technica headphones I'm
using a blue Yeti microphone ducky
keyboard
SteelSeries mouse and I'm using rain
meets on top of Windows to make it look
more nice I've got two monitors and yeah
hello welcome to my setup to it
we here we have an iMac Corsair SP 2500
speakers apple trackpad Corsair keyboard
Mad Catz
Mouse [ __ ] amplifier and DAC biodynamic
and Sennheiser headphones also this
mouse pad is rather unique is it's used
for cleaning dogs but I follow the
internet it looked like a great mouse
bad for everything I have here if you
want to find them just Google that
thanks for watching hey guys it's my
room setup video for the 2014 mkbhd
youtube color I just
to show you my cable management system
so you can get yours done as well as you
see I use plastic wall mounts and velcro
strips here's my sub and my power supply
that drives the computer and the hard
drives so that's it guys I hope you
enjoyed it and I hope you get your cable
management done as well here and
subscribe to mph d for more awesome
videos bye
this is my 2012-2015 setup that's the
expected lifetime it's sort of a stealth
workstation slash gaming rig slash media
center the PC is running on a 10
gigabytes ddr3 RAM a Intel Core i5 35 70
K overclocked to 4.5 gigahertz while
being cooled by a corsair h 100 why it's
all inside a corsair carbide 330 R and
powering both the desktop monitor and
the TV I live in a very tiny studio
apartment is a XFX Radeon HD 7950 hello
I'm Kip ESD this is what my setup looks
like and this is where I spend most of
time with so you know you can basically
see a bad nexus and I used to be a big
fan of Apple products but I you know now
I know I'm into Android is all because
of you so basically I spend most of my
time here thanks a lot
hey guys my desk setup is pretty simple
I've got my iMac right down there in the
center to do all of my work on when I'm
not at my desk I had my iPad Mini to
check emails watch videos and said what
you won't see on every desk are these
two years B's they came with def punks
random access memories collectors box
I've got a nice big desk but I won't go
through everything I will mention my
hi-fi man
HD 400 had phones though which sound
very good with my aun tube DAC and amp
which looks very nice in the dark
most importantly though my fan
if you tally levels here in response to
Marcos this is my entire workspace
[Music]
other guy never won this is Tom and this
is my setup
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so these are the setups that
have a laptop running the show or have a
laptop featured front-and-center getting
the majority of the work done this is my
setup the hackintosh a nice monitor a
foam stand all on this glossy desk and
then the rubik's cube what's going on
mkbhd subscribers and marques we got my
setup right here we have a macbook pro
13 inch Audio Technica m50 s the best
headphones in the world couple
controllers chrome Edition for the 360
underneath we got the ps3 side-by-side
with the 360 and a 3dsxl in the corner
very simple clean setup and then to top
it all off we have my Zenith 50-inch
plasma thanks for watching guys what's
up guys this is a quick setup tour of my
current office space the heart of my
setup
is the latest 13-inch apple macbook air
for additional productivity I have a
27-inch secondary display when mobile
I'm either using my iPad Mini with
Retina display or my iPhone 5s which is
currently being used to film this video
as for networking and backup I have a
three terabyte Apple time-capsule with
an additional 2 terabyte hard drive
complementing my setup is my home
theater which includes an Xbox Apple TV
and a ridiculously oversized sound
system alright guys thanks for watching
I hope you enjoyed myself too
[Music]
hey guys Iger here with my setup to her
so first I have the late 2011 my boo pro
2015 inches a 23 inch Samsung display
1080p LED Magic Mouse Apple keyboard
through the SX sell my books in the
journal for my major iPad air gameboy
color atomic purple some song headphones
wii u ps4 handhelds and accessories and
that's it
I hope you guys liked it my setup is
based on an Ikea gun onto desk and I got
a MacBook Air and a Windows machine
running Google into as my second
computer on it the knife of air is
connected to an Acer monitor and my
audio system as well as an Apple
keyboard and a razor Gaming Mouse
I tried to keep the cable management as
clean as possible on the laptop
workstation hey guys this is my desk
right here it's a pretty simple task
which are assembled from Ikea and one
good thing is I print a shelf on here to
lift up my monitor a little bit and that
kept me place to put my ps3 in there you
have my clips from media 2.1 speakers
and my iPad Mini retina display and half
the 15 inch retina MacBook Pro and
underneath it it's the M stand and I put
my USB hub underneath it and also a
couple of hard disks and I do have my
wireless keyboard and mouse yep that's
it
hey mkbhd fans welcome to my setup here
I have a 24 inch asus monitor 2 external
hard drives for my photos and videos and
a Cisco dual band dd-wrt router this is
all powered by my tablet pc and HP
EliteBook 27 60 p with Windows 8 the
touchscreen works great with OneNote for
taking notes in class and I also have
the docking station so I have to mess
with any cables I love my makeup
bookshelf speakers packed with my little
5 stereo amp and think they look and
sound amazing for only 70 bucks hi guys
this is my setup right here I got my
13-inch MacBook Air Xbox 360 pretty
large single monitor a couple of Xbox
controllers actually over here I have my
Bose speakers for surround sound audio
and I also have a Xbox game stand too
that I custom built in wood shop key
wireless charging and lastly I got my
piano keyboard for jamming out once in a
while thanks for watching right so
here's the setup
we got a 58 inch desk for ten dollars a
20 inch monitor my dad bought for $200
and here's the 24 inch monitor I got for
60
they wrapped some gaming mouse which I
got for 45 these speakers I got for 15
cuz I had a missing leg and fifties 110
brand new Bamboo tablet free from a
hand-me-down rock book air for 380 old
mono but damn 380 i phone 5 64 gigabyte
and don't forget this wipe everything
down welcome to my desk true I have two
desks on my right desk
some photos for school to battles
cookies and my wallet on my left desk is
my 2012 MacBook Pro and the lauritas set
520 sweet speaker system in front of my
macbook is my iPod Touch 4th generation
and an other Broonzy for my iPhone 5s
hope you enjoyed it
[Music]
hey there this is Ryan Ryan tomorrow on
Twitter this is my studio set up for
monitors on a custom Windows desktop a
fantastic Maki mixer and the 2011
MacBook Air all of this is for editing
podcasts and programming
welcome to the Box desire today I'm
going to show you guys my setup on my
workspace I have my gaming monitor
attached to my laptop as well as my
gaming consoles
on the top one of the highlights is my
shelf with all my videogames and
collectibles finally another highlight
has to be my chair
it's a Herman Miller perfect for long
sessions that's pretty much for my set
up thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi guys welcome to my 2014 setup tour on
my desk I have a macbook pro 13 inch i
have clips pro media stereo speakers
with a subwoofer down below on top of
that is a guitar amp that I used to play
along with the bass on the right hand
side of my desk I have a NFC chip to use
with my Android Samsung Galaxy s4 also
chromecast a Xbox 360 with headphones
for online gaming is sanyo 27-inch TV
and then moving along I also have
another Xbox 360 with a 32 inch vizio to
play games with my friends
thanks guys hey what's going on guys I'm
team psycho and this is my submission
mkbhd setup to a project I hope you guys
are enjoying the video I definitely will
and this is my desk this is my setup
it's an l-shaped desk I really like it
and I keep that side of my desk clear
for homework and stuff and I never keep
my desk the same all my displays are at
most the time changing and that's an a
certain AP monitor which is connected to
my macbook pro and iphone and he's just
chillin and that's it thanks for
watching hope that you guys enjoy the
rest of the video what's up guys crows
on here and this is my setup from left
to right I have my 32 inch sony bravia
tv iPad Mini Hauppauge HD PVR
13 inch Toshiba Satellite laptop the ps3
and ps4 and of course when I got a lay
back a little bit I've got my pool
noodle footrest thanks for watching I
hope you enjoyed hey what's up guys
today I got a really short desk setup
video it was my 15-inch MacBook Pro it's
hooked up to this 22 inch Samsung
monitor I use it along with my HP
keyboard and my Logitech MX performance
Mouse I also got a wireless headphone
from Philips and I hope you enjoyed this
really short video goodbye
hello mkbhd fans this is my college dorm
room setup we'll start off with the Asus
23 inch monitor which is hooked up to my
15 inch HP laptop next we have both
Logitech wireless keyboard and Logitech
wireless trackball mouse we have a I pad
with Retina display here and for audio
we have Bose speakers here and here as
well as my V motocross beta and 100's
hooked up to the wall on a simple
thumbtack thanks hello guys doggy here
and this is my setup my main computer is
a retina MacBook Pro 13 inch with the
Hesse full processor in it also I have
an extra screen for added productivity
and that's because he I'm also using a
separate keyboard for my secondary
monitor and in case of our dragon attack
I have my swords
hello its GoPro guy 12th year with my
set up tour because I share a desk with
someone else I like to keep everything
compact and organized starting on the
Left I have my ps3 and real fight
controllers as well as my fight cupboard
15 on my desk I have some drawers a few
placeholders my microphone and my Nexus
5 after that I got my laptop from my
mouse one unique thing about my desk is
my microphone thought isn't the best it
works well for my purposes and ultra
nice - that's it for my setup bye hello
Henning here so my death setup is pretty
straightforward just a 2010 MacBook Pro
hooked up to a 23 inch tall monitor some
headphones and two hard drives for
backups and extra space I use it mostly
for editing in some indie gaming but
what I really love above my setup is
that within a few seconds it is
completely mobile since it is a laptop
after all so I can easily edit on the go
with all my data with me and that's my
setup thanks for watching bye
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up guys the sidetrack 411 and
this is my desk and set of tour for 2014
for the mkbhd project now starting
farthest away we have my lamp a lens to
my microphone my 13 inch MacBook Pro
which is fairly well spec and I have one
of my favorite pieces which is my 22
inch 1080p monitor just under that is my
4 port USB 3.0 hub my iPhone 5 my Nexus
7 2013 model and my iPad air 32 okay
finally we have my Logitech k760 and my
performance mouse and X set of tour I
have a speaker right here and then I
have a TV monitor got the Nexus 7 2013
the Nexus 4 and then our laptop
connected to the monitor and then a
speaker right there okay guys know so
hopefully you guys enjoyed ICU Linux
[Music]
you
hey guys this is my response to mkbhd
setup to her video and this is my setup
the thing I like about my setup is that
it's clean simple and not cluttered my
room has a black theme to it with a few
accents here and there and for when I
need to do work my mate was completely
placed near me a fun fact about the
setup is that it used to just me a
laptop but after looking at mkbhd old
setup and his 2012 tour it inspired me
to look around and that's how I found
the square monitor which I now use on a
regular basis so I guess the moral of
this video is to look around because you
never know you could find
[Music]
I'm going to start with my Logitech
performance MX mouse my iPhone 5 my
macbook pro 13 inch Retina display I
have a Dell XPS 8500 desktop a dell
wireless keyboard and a dell 27-inch
ultra sharp display and an Epson 545
work force printer in the corner and my
fender stratocaster american vintage
reissue 1957 in sunburst
hey what's up guys my name is Matt and
this is my setup it's pretty basic but
it has everything that I need to get on
my video production photography and
graphic design work done for my computer
I'm using aspect out 13-inch MacBook Pro
that I take to school and back but when
I'm at home I connect it to my 27-inch
AOC monitor for my videos including the
clip I'm recording right now I use a
blue spark microphone and it really gets
the job done well now there's certainly
more to my setup but I'm gonna keep this
short if you have any questions feel
free to hop over to my channel and ask
away thanks I'll see you there
here we have an overview of my main
thought of as you can see first we have
my two main monitors which are my
element of 720p TV and my Dell 2005 @pw
on top of that I have my Logitech webcam
next that is my iPhone 3GS and there I
have my wireless keyboard and wireless
mouse made by General Electric under
there I have my laptop powering
everything which is awesome it's the
dell inspiron in 50/50 going to the left
I have my zoom h1 microphone which I
used to record everything and my Yamaha
keyboard which I used to play the piano
I love this keyboard and it's great for
everybody sitting on the music stand of
that is my first generation iPad Mini
which I absolutely love my unique
computer setup starts with my Samsung
27-inch full 1080p C 750 monitor you can
see my playstation 4 tucked in the
corner over there now look up you can
see my Logitech c920 HD webcam sitting
atop my monitor here's my Razer Nostromo
from my left hand my Gunners pastorate
40s Razer Naga expert clips 2.1 system
what's unique about my setup is my
laptop sits on top of my desk with the
dock connecting it to the monitor with
an HDMI cord the heart and soul of my
setup is my ancient keyboard
what is going on my kiss this my set up
tour we've got my tripods and we don't
have a lot of time so I'm just gonna
show you a very faster router my
keyboard performance miles MX mile and
for YouTube video production macbook air
playstation headset I popped my Andy
called provides sound free Bluetooth
speaker and that's it guys thanks for
watching
hey guys what's going on this is my HD
tone others and this is my setup I'll
start with the cameras Canon t1 i
contour roam to canon powershot 300 at
HS Boston speakers monitor is a samsung
sync master at p2 7 7 0 very nice 1
millisecond response time 2000 early
2013 MacBook Pro retina the i7 and the
microphone is a samson c01u hey what is
up ladies and gentlemen and welcome to
my setup video starting off I have my
hbg 62 laptop with my Xbox one
controller and a second monitor on the
second shelf I have my Xbox one Kinect
along with my Xbox one and a GoPro hero3
and lastly I my 32 inch Hannspree HDTV
attached with the roxio game capture HD
pro to my xbox one thanks for watching
and have a wonderful day it's a quick
overview of my home setup inside of my
desk I have an HP laptop with an HP
printer that pops connected to a Samsung
22 inch monitor I have a Windows Surface
tablet Google Nexus 7 tablet Samsung
Windows Phone Samsung Chrome OS laptop
and Bose speakers so I have multiple
operating systems Windows 7 Windows 8
Chrome OS and Android and it's also my
main charging station use this one is
the HP Envy 4
look this wireless mouse this the HP
Envy 14 touch smart not look hi my name
is Ellis and welcome to my setup tour
2014 first up I've got my Lenovo monitor
vertically set up to my retina MacBook
Pro my MacBook has a quad core i7
processor with 8 gigs of RAM also
there's my iPhone I then also use a one
terabyte Western Digital hard drive and
a 500 gigabyte old laptop hard drive I
uses a Time Machine backup I then also
have a Logitech five to one speaker
system thank you for watching what's up
marques it's hi Otto and this is my mono
so set up until I can get a desk so this
is my blue Yeti microphone and a 15 inch
MacBook Pro that I used for video
editing as well as the sony handycam
that I use to fill in those videos I've
got an iPad air that I use as a
teleprompter plus a ps4 controller for
when I get bored and need distractions
here's my custom Moto X and underneath
that we have a mkbhd business card so I
love your videos man thanks for watching
[Music]
each other I can see it in your eyes
take a step back outside
you shadow
[Music]
take a step back
[Music]
what's going on everybody my name is
Tomas this is a video response to mkbhd
setup tour project 2014 I was lucky
enough to be featured in his setup tour
2012 video and I thought I would submit
again I'd like to highlight my 2007
black MacBook I brought this thing back
to life from a Cola spill and now it is
my media server check out the video
description to see my endeavor in a blog
post form I run a 2.7 gigahertz 2012 non
retina MacBook Pro that contains 16
gigabytes of RAM and a 512 SSD
user-created fusion drive anyway
shoutout to mkbhd and if you haven't
already head on over and subscribe to
his channel also you're invited to come
and check out my channel as well if you
like what you see feel free to subscribe
as always thanks for taking the time to
watch my video take care hey guys what's
up Alec here from 404 Tech and this is
my setup now you may be thinking huh
that's a pretty wimpy setup but no
worries I've got a brand new hack Pro to
be built any day now so I guess we'll
start with my 13-inch 2012 MacBook Air
used for all my editing and my Google
Nexus 5 next to my galaxy s2 CI rocket
along with my samsung s 27 C 35 0h 27
inch LCD monitor thanks for watching hi
everyone this is my setup for my
computer I just used a laptop with a
wireless mouse I have a nexus 7 and a
pair of Sony headphones at the other
side of the room is a sony bravia 3d TV
with an Xbox 360 for playing games and
the last thing is my logitech sound
system which is connected to the TV as
well as my laptop
[Music]
welcome to my setup which includes the
late 2013 MacBook Pro sitting on a cool
master jazz prost and attached to a 23
inch Dell monitor with a glossy display
right next to it is my 22 inch Samsung
monitor connected to my old-school
Windows PC that features the legendary
Intel Q 6600 processor
overall I like to keep my setup as
simple and as clean as possible
hi guys so here's my setup of your two
laptops but it's still a pretty basic
one
my main laptops is an HP Pavilion g6
it's great for school and I like it I
also have a nexus 7 2013 that I used for
media consumption YouTube and Internet I
have an iPod Touch 4G that I barely use
and my Nexus 4 which I love thanks guys
for watching and see you next time my
keyboard mouse and wear trust my phones
at night my 2013 13 inch MacBook Pro
hooked up to my thing 1920 by 1080 23
inch Asus Manila this is my Skullcandy
ABT's for listening to my music when I'm
free and my speakers are the money gear
this is my current set-up right here and
I think the most unique part is the fact
that I have my air pollution headphones
right here on top of this cardboard
cylinder holding it all together is this
little piece of roll of tape here and
coming out of that is the cords for my
Dell speakers which are hidden right
behind my HP laptop that is my setup hey
guys what's up Tim here with talkin tech
comm and this is my thirty second setup
tour video for mkbhd as you can see on
the left side of my desk I have a five
USB port box for all of my devices I
have my neck
five sitting on an inductive charger and
the highlight of my setup is definitely
Google glass it's a really unique and
innovative piece of tech and I've really
enjoyed using it on the right side of my
desk I have a 2013 Nexus 7 and beside
that I have a 240 gigabyte solid state
drive from Kingston and in the center of
my desk is my late 2013 October MacBook
Pro it gets all my editing in school
work done
you
hey what's up guys two hands from
Austria here this is my setup this is
the Samsung Galaxy Tab 10.1 my Nexus 4
with the wireless charging or my laptop
which I'm using mainly for school my PT
X 300 Bluetooth speakers which I love
because of the great sound and the NFC
connectivity and my Microsoft Surface
pro thanks for watching hey guys this is
my submission for the setup to project
2014 here on the right I have this
beaker / doc but analysts as a speaker
for my 15 inch Samsung laptop here is my
next 7 day dreaming I also have this
little box here with things like
microfiber cloth SD cards all that stuff
then on the back of my desk I have these
LED lights they are really cool you can
also change the color I also have this
neat thing on the wall here I don't know
I don't know how it's called yeah here
on the left unstable I also have the
Galaxy Note pro 12.2 you can't hear no
magazine UX so yeah guys this has been
my setup I hope you enjoyed it and
thanks for watching
everybody's Alex here and I'm taking
part in mkbhd said after 2014 this is
basically how I work I'm editor over at
Android headlines and I got a 24 inch
monitor over here which is powered by my
HP Envy 15 over there along with the
logitech wireless keyboard and mouse i'm
motox of course my Pepsi right now gave
me only some headphones and moto skip
over there and various other things that
I'm either reviewed or working out
reviewing over here
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys for my setup I like to keep it
really simple so while we're here I have
my MacBook Pro 13 inch my headphones and
Racer abysus for mouse and over here I
have my 32 inch TV and my ps3
hello mkbhd viewers um my desk setup is
great for like people who want to use
their laptop for everything but wanted
to feel like a desktop computer when
they have it at their desk so like I
have it hidden inside that drawer there
with a hole drilled in the back to hide
and route all the wires through and then
it's also great as like an audio setup
because I have a boom stand mounted
inside the ceiling which you don't see
very often and then the wires are just
kind of running around the back there
and yeah that's about all I can make
time for so thanks to a fire my 2014
setup is just a little different
powering everything is the 2013 11 inch
MacBook Air which is really handy when
you just need to grab something and make
a run for it
the rest of the essentials are covered
by an apple airport extreme and a
Motorola surfboard to deliver some
crispy internet speeds last but not
least there's my desk which also doubles
as my chair I'm a pastor and as such I
need to be on the go so whether it's at
home at church or just in the car this
is where I store everything and my
workforce a samsung 550 a Chromebook 11
Nexus 7 2012 and the new Nexus 5 and
really that baby is the work force
whether it's hot spotting for my
Chromebooks or just answering emails all
right guys so this is a tour of my desk
my desk is real simple just consists of
a laptop and then a keyboard nothing
really else all right so first this is
my notebook I just write anything that's
on my mind pretty much for videos then
we have my one terabyte g drive then
it's my lamp here's another view of my
desk next this is a very old keyboard
pretty much I just found it in my
basement and then here is my 13 inch
late 2011 macbook pro hi guys welcome to
my setup tool so my setup is pretty
minimalistic I've gone for this sleek
clean only minier
would look I'm a filmmaker and I use my
MacBook Pro Retina display as my main
editing computer at the start of the day
I simply tap in to see all the
information I need to get going and when
I'm done editing I can watch the final
result on my TV across the room thanks
for watching guys
hey guys what's going on this is my ex
g2 and others and this is my setup I'll
start with the cameras
Canon t1i contour roam to again the
power shot 300 at HS awesome speakers
monitor is a Samsung sync master at p2
seven seven zero very nice one
millisecond response time mm early 2013
MacBook Pro retina of the eye seven and
the microphone is a samson c01u hey
everyone this is my setup run off of an
early 2011 MacBook Pro 15 inch what I
love about my setup is that across my
Samsung Chromebook my external monitor
and my macbook pro I have enough space
so that everything I need can be open at
once and I don't have to keep switching
windows what I also love is that I can
quickly switch between my drawing tablet
and my mouse or I can pull my boom mic
down if I need to talk or just push it
out of the way if I need to do something
else
hi guys this is a quick tour of my super
minimal setup as you can see we have a
13-inch MacBook Pro a keyboard tray
gripper process an external drive tray
then we are creative t20 that provides
some good vibes a weather station and
that's it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone i'm william here's a quick
overview of my setup I use a 2011
13-inch MacBook Pro the one terabyte
sshd my display is a del s 23 40mm with
the VESA adapter an amount that I can
position about anywhere I want to so I'm
a student and I take my computer to
class a lot sometimes I just need to
grab my computer and go so I got a
cottage at thunderbolt station this
allows me to run audio-video and two
hard drives there just one Thunderbolt
cable into my laptop oh yeah and it adds
USB 3 capabilities to mine on USB 3
laptop thanks for watching hey YouTube
what's up is Nano prints 93 and this is
my 30 second set of tour video for
marques Brownlee I have just a MacBook
Air 2011 a 32 inch Hitachi HDTV that's
wall-mounted and I my iPad Mini with my
zeg folio case which is the greatest
accessory I've ever purchased for any
Apple product yeah my 5s my xbox would
be 60 a couple controllers you have my
Bose speaker is right left and bass
hopefully you guys liked this video and
hopefully we put on his setup tour 2014
thank you
here's my entry for mkbhd DS for project
2014 I currently use Apple's wireless
keyboard magic mouse and Magic Trackpad
have a 2 terabyte g drive and under that
is a 4 terabyte gr8 next I have the mid
2012 baseline retina MacBook Pro 15 inch
that's all for my set up and I hope you
enjoyed retina macbook pro 1 USB cable
USB hub with blu-ray burner and hard
drives mouse and keyboard hey guys so
here's my quick dorm set up tour up top
I have dual 24 inch Dell monitors but
what was my custom-built Mac that is
part of my favorite part
I put the specs up on the screen the
peripherals there's the Apple wireless
keyboard and trackpad along with the
razor mouse for audio there are Audio
Technica headphones sitting on a large
binder clip I have a 15 inch macbook pro
that we use for classwork eight gigabit
nexus 5 and finally an HP printer
alongside my Wacom Bamboo tablet thanks
for watching
hey mkbhd this is Jake and this is my
setup - or real quick hopefully I can
get this done in 30 seconds anyway there
are my headphones which I actually
really like the Skullcandy Slayers
they're pretty high quality for what
they are all roads lead to my Mac I've
got GarageBand and my pedal editor setup
there's my guitar josephine the she's
very special to me and there's my pedal
and my amp it's tiny
but it works anyway that's the setup see
ya
hello and he Bhd audience this is my
setup I have a monitor hooked up to my
MacBook Air and I also have an amplifier
and a pedal for my guitar I also have a
pair of studio monitors and this is my
guitar it's a 2013 Gibson SG and it
plays wonderfully so yeah guys thanks
for watching hey guys here's my death
setup for 2014 my MacBook Air 2012 it's
being projected onto this new act
monitor and then there's my Apple iPhone
5 my Apple wireless keyboard and my
Logitech M 325 Mouse then my Google
Nexus 7 from 2013 and my audio box USB
from Studio One here's my Yamaha
keyboard microphone amps guitar pedals
and my electric guitar I hope you all
enjoyed this video
adios
[Music]
myself tour starts with my chair
followed by my nice desk large desk with
my 1080p aces 24 inch monitor right
there connected to a 2013 Haswell
MacBook Air 13 inch with my Logitech
Solar keyboard my mouse propel both
speakers a terabyte external hard disk
and my quadcopter project that I'm
working on currently and a nice lamp hey
what is up guys this is my setup the
feature is the 227 inch HP Pavilion
monitors their great Thunderbolt Display
alternatives this area also serves as my
recording studio so I have some of my
guitars hanging on the wall including my
Gibson acoustic in my 1965 harmony
Bobcat this is my main go-to computer
for editing it's a MacBook Pro 15 inch
and I run mainly the Adobe Creative
Suite but also I have some other
programs my newest auditioning equipment
for filming is the Canon c100 usually my
setup has the MacBook Pro running the
screen on the right and my Mac Mini
running the screen on the left and I'll
use it for media and things like that
here is my workspace it's got my 2 pound
USB power display connected to my Asus
laptop and my monitor and the ace plate
of course in the corner got my wireless
keyboard and mouse and my bookbag and
that's it set to go hi I'm this is my
setup store to start with the iPad air
and above that are the audio technica
ath and 50s and above that those are
just so Philips speakers but next to
that is the star of the show the MacBook
Pro Retina 15-inch with chief force
video card this is just a keyboard from
Logitech it's wireless plus the mouse it
was with it and next to that is my HTC
One from iminium and buff that is a
secondary monitor hey guys this is Megan
and this is my desk my setup is powered
by my 2011 MacBook Air on a 12th south
stand
attached to a 22-inch external monitor
it's a nice simple clean setup perfect
for shooting YouTube video reviews for
you guys thanks for watching
Cheers
[Music]
it's going on screw surfer from mobile
chaos went over a set up tour for mkbhd
set up tour project over there you see
an Asus AC 66u wireless router running a
Comcast blast 50 megabits down Asus 23
inch monitor over here is a MacBook Pro
Retina late 2012 edition over here rest
of my daily drivers in Nokia 95 on top
of a wireless Qi charger basically I
have HDMI out to the monitor and then
all the sound comes off at this I home
speaker up here and that is a 2nd gen
iPod touch that still works very slow
but it works and yeah that's my set oh
thanks hey guys this is my simple and
clean desk setup I'm quite happy with at
the moment including my Nexus 5 and iPad
the new 15-inch MacBook Pro and two
buzzer sounding wireless speaker in case
this is made for studying and being
productive for me the power of the mech
is more than enough obviously I don't
like cables too much that's why I [ __ ]
UI charger for my Nexus to keep it
healthy all the time the huge window in
front of me brings a lot of daylight and
a fantastic view this was inspired the
mkbhd thanks for watching
[Music]
hi guys this is my setup for submission
all powered by a Lenovo y50 laptop
starting from the left I have my ATM 50
headphones my 8020 20 USB microphone the
screen is an Asus IPS 1080p monitor with
a Wacom Bamboo pen a level 10m gaming
mouse and a quick-fire to cave
mechanical keyboard most notably my
laptop is being held up by a mini crane
which will provide room for the mouse
and the hidden Xbox 360 connected to the
monitor to the side is my work desk and
my guitars and it's running the Nintendo
2011 screensaver thanks for watching
here's a quick look at my setup I've got
a 15 inch Apple MacBook Pro with Retina
display an Apple USB super drive away
come welcome I don't know what you call
it
graphics tablet and giggety what's going
on YouTube this is what with josh do and
this is my setup I use in a Susur
Republic of gamers g7 PI 0 J H to edit
video on I have a 23 inch full HD at
suits monitor and I use these ath MVP
based on mq phd's recommendation I love
these things
zoom h2n for portable audio recording
and the Samson meteor mic for doing
voiceovers for with the dub you from
your pro which is my editing software
alright so now we're getting into the
setups that all have something very
different about them this is the uniques
category and while watching each of
these setups it'll probably be pretty
easy to tell why each of them was
selected for this pretty inspiring
category check these out
this is my new setup that I just
finished I'm using the new six core Mac
Pro connected to 2 at 24 inch a C's pro
art monitors via DisplayPort I wanted to
make a very clean and simple looking
setup by creating a lot of free space on
my desk and hiding as much wiring as
possible in order to do that I moved all
my equipment against the wall and group
wires together with zip ties straps and
wire hoses it significantly cleaned up
the look compared to the mess of wires
it was before it's not a hard thing to
do but
is time-consuming enquires a lot of
planning pretty standard desk to manos
and walleskya shout out to the Wacom
Bamboo that thing's pretty sweet but
where's the Mac
it's on a custom mount behind the TV
laser cut acrylic some nuts and some
blue tag hey my name is Daniel and this
is my setup this is my computer right
here yeah this for a while
upgraded over time this is my Logitech G
400 miles it's a great Mouse and my mad
stacks on top of my receiver my numark
mixtrack pro 2 and my quadraphonic
speaker setup
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and my nifty mic setup until I get a
legit condenser mic and a boom arm for
online radio live streaming that I do
thanks hello everyone this is daniel
from didymus studio and this is my
submission to the mkbhd setup tour
[Music]
hey guys just wanted to do a real quick
tour of my studio just to show you guys
what I've got going on I do live in a
dorm room but I managed to fit all my
stuff in here this is my main setup over
here with my keyboard my speaker's I do
run Ableton Live on a custom-built PC
and then over here I've got a smaller
studio for when people want to
collaborate with me run by a MacBook Pro
and then over here I've got my main
keyboard which is an 88 key Yamaha p1 55
thanks a lot for watching guys hey guys
how's it going
so first up we have my 2012 MacBook Air
I'm at 42 inch TV and all the way to the
right my hackintosh next up we have my
playstation 3 my HTC butterfly and also
my Sony digital photo frame on the desk
we have a razer blackwidow irate Orochi
and also a Logitech m70 5 marathon mouse
underneath the desk we find my DIY cable
management solutions using toilet paper
tubes on the other side of the room
there's a canon printer my headphones
and also my 4th generation iPod touch on
a dark connected to the Bose music
monitors well that's it for now thanks
for watching
what's up mkbhd fans my name is jay mohr
and this is my setup tour i do a lot of
music photography and video production
using programs ranging from pro tools to
all the Adobe applications I'm using an
M box 3 and a Golden Age pre 73 to
record vocals I mainly use my native
instruments maschine to produce
instrumentals along with my 88 key and
Mario piano I have the Mac EMR fives as
my studio monitors and to the right of
them is where I hang up all my
headphones thanks for watching and
follow me at JM our presents
Nathan Drake's here with my 2014 mkb
submission for that setup to work
highlight of my system is going to be my
audio system for my computer which is a
Peachtree audio deco 65 integrated
amplifier running Martin Loeb in motion
fifteens as well as a Arielle's t0
subwoofer I've been going around my room
here as you can see everything else we
have
Martin Logan towers on my main setup for
my computers also hooked up with by Oppo
blu-ray player ps3 ps4 xbox one and
panasonic TV Haymarket this is my setup
what you can see here is my gaming
computer with a GTX 780 and a 46 70 K
and my samsung 1080p in one of the which
I've because it has door HDMI inputs for
the computer and the ps3 the coolest
part about my setup is this human scale
in one of the rooms I picked up for eBay
for about 80 bucks even though it
retails for about $300 and to touch the
desk by this custom aluminium plate
mkbhd this is my setup video here's my
desk it's a little bit messy overall I'm
okay with that down there is my computer
and over here is my powerline network
adapter and basically what it allows me
to do is allows me to use land and even
though my router is on the other side of
the house and I think that's really
useful because I was getting tired of
Wi-Fi and how it works is I have two of
them one connects on my computer as such
and one connects to my router and it
uses my house as power grid to connect
the two LAN cables also I'm shooting
this in my moto X and I would not bought
this phone if we ran out for your videos
so huge things for that
hi this is my setup I'm tall and I
couldn't fit under a normal table so I
build my own from scratch
below the monitors there are outlets and
switches for lights and play fire and
starting the PC
the PC sits in the back strip - two
beams so it gets enough airflow and as
little dust as possible hey guys this is
my current desk set up everything is run
by a 2011 MacBook Pro and to the left
I've got a 3d mouse for SolidWorks and
to the right I have a Microsoft touch
mouse which makes the Windows 8 more
bearable
the extra monitor is mounted to the base
of it iMac g4 which lets it swivel and
then I also have an overflowing fish
tank for they made so this is my
workstation setup tour we've got two
monitors here I've got a pair of bear
dynamic headphones iPad no phone and
mouse by madcatz a jar of juice because
the jug is not enough and then if you
come down here you'll see I've actually
raised my desk up with some stools I got
at the hardware store because I had back
problems sitting down all day so I now
have a standing desk then got hackintosh
in nice NZXT case and then there's a
little button I've installed under here
or if you do this it turns this on so
you can work at night and see the
keyboard noises so yeah that's my um my
little setup woohoo I wanted to achieve
a balance between size and power I have
the tools to get anything done in the
compact form factor a pair of em audio
bx8 speakers which are more likely to
cause deafness before breaks I'm using
the alesis master control as an audio
interface and control surface the iPad
is my preferred device to control
sessions and Logic Pro X I'm a pianist
ends the 88-key roland keyboard and a
real piano located to my right for all
my classical needs native instruments
maschine mainly used for beef production
what's up everybody its electric potato
here and this is my setup tour video
starting from the left is my stereo
slash record player and right next to
that is my DIY headphone stand which is
made out of stained wood PVC pipe and
electrical tape which holds my HT 28
pros and I have my plunger switch
keyboard which sits right next to my G
100's Mouse and my entire setup is
powered by my gaming / editing rig and
all my cables are managed by this vacuum
tubing and it is all lit up by these
LEDs thanks for watching what is up guys
NK Bhd fans I'm pretty excited to show
my desk because I made my monetarist and
it's
with my dad underneath my monitor stands
I have my xbox 360 some speakers and
some accessories for making my videos
and some posters my main keyboard is
from Apple and also my mouse is from
Apple and this is my bean bag that I use
for gaming so thank you guys so much for
watching
hey guys this is josh your welcome to my
setup tour i've got 3 27 inch 1080p
monitors a 32 inch TV a a sous an 50-60
xbox one ps4 and what makes myself
special is my two drum sets I've got our
Pacific CX maple and a-rollin td7
electronic kit and here is my tower and
the whole setup thanks guys so I have
two screens which is useful for editing
one for panels the other ones have
viewers 27 and 22 inches these are loud
speakers I built myself they sound
really wonderful right in the back I've
placed some cool LED lights as a Mac
user I've been rocking a hackintosh
which is both cheap and fast
I used a field recorder as a mic and an
old keyboard which is great for typing
as well as a Logitech mouse it's all
about simplicity and functionality of
course good looks is nice too that's it
and thanks for watching guys in my man
cave we have a retina MacBook Pro that
is actually the workstation sitting on
top of a hackintosh in a mac pro case
cables running through the wall powering
a pair of 27-inch Apple cinema display
monitors with an iPad air wireless
keyboard and mouse and trackpad super
drive and the monitors are on double
swivel elbows so I can position anywhere
I want horizontal or vertical
independently this room makes for a
quiet and effective working environment
our setup at mobile gadget is simple and
intuitive we currently use 2 max with
Pro Retina notebooks and Windows
desktops that we built ourselves as well
as Chromebook pixel there's a snowball
mic that we use to record audio with and
an iPad air for video skirts our daily
drivers are iPhone 5s
behind the set we used a Nikon d50 200
for recording video part we use a broad
range of operating systems as you can
see which for us is the thing that we
believe stands out about our setup and
our YouTube video reviews we believe
it's a good thing to have experience
with different operating systems
especially when you're reviewing welcome
to my setup and this is the centerpiece
6 27-inch displays on a custom-built
desk connected to a late 2013 Mac Pro
but for me a setup is not all about the
main computer it's about an experience
and I try and add to that with all of my
own little touches I've got a Power Mac
g5 coffee table that I built here I've
got some of my guitars on the wall and
one of my favorite computers an iMac g4
in the corner here's my 4k gaming
machine stroke workstation a 39 inch 4k
display and then connected to my
hackintosh with the latest core i7 and
jaws 79 70's on my desk I have a
Logitech g600 wireless mouse right next
to that is my a serve III gaming laptop
dual booting Windows 8.1 and Ubuntu and
then there's my sony MDR v6 headphones
and then right next to that not on my
desk is my audio technica at2020 for
recording let's plays beneath my
computer you'll find a couple hard
drives Dual Shock 4 for playing PC games
and my DAC and as you can see it's a
standing desk much health
you
hey what's up guys it's Isaac about
managed to shake and today I have a
short best to rush from tour starting at
my desk I have the Samsung Galaxy Tab 2
7.0 apple bluetooth wireless keyboard
and my HTC One some random stuff on my
desk my bed lighting equipment and my
tripod for my camera and right here we
have a Philips 26 inch flat screen TV
along with two stereo speakers from Polk
Audio and what makes my room - were
unique is that I have my earbuds hanging
on these tacks it's very useful and it
looks neat and organized thanks guys for
watching and have a great day hey guys
and welcome to my death setup for 2014
as you can see it may not be too
interesting was playing on my butt from
2009 running Mavericks what is very
unique about my setup is that I have
dedicated the rest of my space with my
Mac collection like Mighty IMAX here at
G free energy for and also I have my
eMac found in my drawer above to it next
my laptop I keep most of my other
devices including an iPhone and iPod and
also I have my iPad to check my social
networks and things anyway that is my
desk set up for mkbhd thanks for
watching
right so I've just got a quick
demonstration of my SL I've got a laptop
here hooked up by VGA HDMI - something's
monitors hooked up to the laptop then
we've got a PS Vita here tablet phone
gaming PC here with running OS X
Mavericks I've got a 5 or 6 power system
with a Raspberry Pi and then also YB
neste gaming system there but the
coolest thing I probably want to show
those turn my lights off is my projector
so yeah it's got Dharma all there
anyways am so thanks watching and I hope
you can serve this video and keep ehe
thinks everyone I'm David
music but my two favorite things in
terms of tech is the evertune bridge a
system that lets you stay in shoes
forever because the other technology I'm
really excited about is my Rica tar
proact so it's got my powered video mic
it's got a guitar ivory pram and these
accessories this lets you plug it into a
digital camera gives it a huge boost and
a much lower noise floor couldn't be
happier
that's it for maybe the big THANK YOU to
mkbhd for all these inspiring tech
videos and of course we're setting up
this setup to work
so this is my setup I have a $2.00 best
monitors a fractal our three case while
trying to focus on this a scalable
management so down here spike thing is
everything tucked into this tray so
where speakers sound everything goes
through there and keeps everything neat
and tidy
yeah hi I'm Simon and this is my setup
hanging on a broken jump stick off the
side of my desk got my headphones on top
I've got six terabytes of storage and
backup a 23 inch 1080p monitor a four
point USB 3.0 hub and a wireless
keyboard and mouse driving it all is my
256 gigabyte service part to plugging in
the USB hub headphones main display port
and power gives me a fully functional
dual 1080p screen desktop setup run by a
surprisingly powerful tablet alright so
for my setup I have a custom-built
gaming PC based off the $750 build guide
by Austin Evans hooked up to a 50 inch
vizio LED HDTV IV wireless Logitech M
310 mouse in the legendary mkbhd red and
black combo unfortunately I have a wired
Logitech classic keyboard 200 that
provides for a pretty crazy wiring setup
the main feature I want to highlight is
the 50 inch vizio LED HDTV which is
absolutely stellar
yes my workstation is in my living room
here's my 50-inch panasonic plasma
television my ps4 Xbox 360 and my
custom-built HTPC which has an HDMI
input similar to the Xbox one person DVR
functionality allowing me to watch two
live TV channels in one time plus u2 and
here are some of my peripherals and
other devices so I get work done
cheerio so this is my setup the
centerpiece is my three 1080p monitors
that make app development a breeze and
gaming loads of fun it may not be the
prettiest but it works well for my
entertainment and study needs the
standout feature of my setup is the
cable management and gas pop-up that
keeps most of the cable clutter off the
floor and the desk hey how's it going
guys my name is Tanner and I am from
maniac for tech and this is my setup
tour so guys starting off with my PC it
has a core i5 46 70 K has 8 gigs of RAM
as well as a gtx 760 graphics card which
you can't handle just about any games
that I throw at it so for my monitor I'm
using a 1080p 32 inch LCD TV made by
insignia but guys I must say my favorite
part of my setup is my Logitech g27
racing wheel shifter and pedal set so is
great for anybody who loves pcs
simracing
and I think is what makes my setup
unique so guys thanks for watching hello
everyone I'm not going to mature setup
I'm using a 13-inch MacBook Pro
connected to a 27 inch Thunderbolt
Display and they're into music music
recording which is why there are lots of
instruments unrelated tech on my desk
I'm using son Howser headphones Koch
synthesizer and a tascam sound card
under my desk also all the effect pedals
and finally my personal favorite and
Fender Telecaster 60 years limited
edition hope you enjoyed it see ya
here is a plastic fold up desk with my
entire setup on it which features the
MacBook Pro from 2011 a Dell monitor a
Logitech speaker system and my iPad
camera and microphone on the side but we
wear my desk isn't that interesting but
what is interesting is location which
actually is in an arcade
what's up mkbhd in fellow viewers this
is my sub tour
front and center got a samsung RC 512
running Windows 7 over here I got a
little Dell Optiplex that I put a boon
to up top got a 360 slim running on a
monitor but the highlight of the video
is gonna be this Nexus 7 we are out of
my car and you may notice that there's a
huge hole in the dash well I happen to
have a nexus 7 that fits perfectly right
there that plays all my music you can
see it's playing Bluetooth audio I can
get navigation because it has a GPS
sensor I just love that thing so peace
out guys
Viper 69 here with my setup tour for
2014 I'm gonna start it off with my
custom desktop computer down there got
it hooked up to two 22 inch Acer LED
monitors got a little Nexus family going
on have a numark mixtrack pro 2 over
here connected to a Sony e-series laptop
got a ps3 dish box and basically
everything connected to this 40 inch
insignia LCD TV so that is my setup for
2014 thank you for watching hi I'm Kay
PhD this is my setup tour well to begin
with this is my headphone stand I got
the idea from your 2012 edition set up
to her here we have my urban ears and my
Sennheiser headphones well if we move on
we have my microphone which defined
pro-us be one that's microphone I'm
using right now if we move further on
that's my homemade pop filter I really
like it that's my keyboard and last but
not least my homemade sound isolation
thank you for watching and I hope you
enjoyed the video
hello everyone and welcome to my setup
tool as you can see this is my workspace
and the thing that I like to highlight
about my setup is the fact that I use
both Mac and PC at the same time without
having to swap out any equipment for
example I as you can see when I'm moving
my mouse right now I can actually
control anything on my windows I can
stop it - my dear
at the screen and if I want to I can
move my cursor over to the Mac that way
and it's the same with my keyboard and
the other thing is I can actually swap
out my main display to use the Mac if I
need to if I'm doing work mainly on the
Mac by just pressing this remote and
everything that was on my main window
before it's not on my the screen on my
right and it's now showing Mac on my
main display and if I want to I can
switch back it's that easy and that's
the end of my video thanks for watching
hey what's up this is Misha Lisa all the
way from Malaysia I'm a huge fan anyway
this is my setup I have my laptop over
there my 32 inch TV over there cuz I
like things become bright yeah it's
basically my whole entertainment system
in one place and then I have sort of my
table over there by the side for really
serious work but otherwise what I'm
doing things sort of design and all that
yeah everything happens over here okay
this is a quick video of my setup I have
my dis over here with file papers and
rulers and wires on the bottom and I
have my disks with my laptop and an Iron
Gym that I keep tome to put my laptop on
because I love standing and typing and a
little folder clipper to hold my
headphones with a mkbhd this is my setup
I thought everybody was doing their
desktop workstation so I changed up and
here's my audio setup for my bedroom
powering the whole thing are my bose
companion two speakers using my airport
express i can play my music wirelessly
youth airplay from my iPhone and Mac I
have a 12 South high-rise dog for charge
of my iPhone well played on music and
what I want to highlight is my pile
record player plugged into the Bose
speakers they sound amazing together
hello marques andric is here from
Australia here is my little look that I
have in the corner of our office so I
have my g27 set up over there for
erasing and my work laptop back up up
top Nexus 7 etc down there I have
shoving in my system here because I have
a lot of little knickknacks with my
reviewing and his phone covers cords USB
sticks blah blah blah heaps and heaps of
it so to keep some level of sanity I
stole this Adi from Ikea for the
shelling there it is this is my setup my
PC is fighting under the bed I have
Microsoft arc keyboards and Microsoft
touch mouse Samsung monitor Philips DVD
player that is connected with my PC I
planted my speakers on the walls and
that's it I'm welcome to my setup which
I menus of graphic design and flight
simulation as you can see I used three
monitors I also used LED strip lights
which I picked off on off Amazon and
they are a nice addition to the rig
powering this is my custom built PC
featuring an Intel Core i5 35 70 K
unlock processor which is overclocked
4.7 gigahertz
it also features sixteen gigabytes of
course I ran an EVGA gtx 660 graphics
card i'm gonna show you my destined up
real quick brahma will start from right
to left here got my custom cool
water-cooled gaming rig go into the
specs but that's kind of irrelevant
moving on
got a dell ultrasharp monitor moving
down I got a Logitech d700 gaming mouse
we've been down to the left we got a
razer blackwidow ultimate keyboard we're
going onto headphones we got a pair of
eight th and 50s from Audio Technica
hanging on a PCI bracket that is zip
tied to my shelf then speaking of audio
we got some old speakers that work just
fine and other than that got one more
thing just for you mkb that's it have a
good day this is my workstation we got
my Marshall headphones here that I
highly recommend got a website that I
sell some Android stuff if you want to
check that out
got my android speaker mouse school I go
to keyboard 32 inch TV there using as my
monitor got some Nexus 7's up there on
the wall it's a decal on one is for one
of the things we sell over here I got my
printer Wii U 3ds PC that I just built
two days ago Wii U Xbox one and my
system for sound one of the cool things
Xbox go home hey marques I wanted to
give you a quick setup tour of my home
theater at the heart of it all is a
custom built PC a Seton quad tuner card
allows me to record for HD channels at
once even though it's a full-fledged PC
we spend most of our time looking at the
Windows Media Center interface we have
access to recorded TV electronic guide
listings Netflix music and movie
libraries the Logitech Harmony 650
remote is so customizable almost
everything is one button press away
including the chromecast that's a quick
setup tour of my home theater while no
one part stands out combined it makes
for a wife approved experience this is
Christian eight to nine today I'll be
bringing you a quick setup to
over here I have my 15-inch Samsung
Chronos hooked up to a 27-inch Asus
display and right here I have my audio
technica Pro 500 mk2 s right here I have
my Apple MacBook with its custom red
logo one thing unique about my setup is
my color changing LED shirt which I can
control using a remote
hey everyone I'm KC Cooper and I'm a
drummer who records and edits audio and
YouTube videos as well as a gamer so I
had to create a workstation that can
handle all three tasks the main specs
are listed on the video but some of the
special features are the hideaway camera
charging in controller station as well
as the hidden Xbox 360 and mixer for my
krk monitors the 32 is for my Apple TV
and the 27 doubles as a monitor for my
retina MacBook and for my Xbox one and
that's my Perl ePro live electronic kit
thanks for checking it out
hi guys it's Dan here from Cape Town
South Africa and this is my workspace on
the left over here you can see my 17
inch laptop that I've had for many years
and because I care about economics
I built this laptop stand which I'm
going to produce and call lap form I
recently bought this 23 inch LG IPS
monitor and within a day of earning it I
bought this Stanford which you can see
adjusts in many ways hey everybody
this is Eric coming to you from Kyoto
Japan just wanted to give you guys a
quick look at what a setup of a media
creator and higher education might look
like complete with do-it-yourself media
cart green screen if you'd like to see
more just check out the link thanks guys
check you later
alright so I'm here for the 2014 setup
tour project I've got a 27-inch monitor
has my ps3 playing on it right now I've
got a custom-built PC I've got two that
monitor and an Apple TV err playing
right now from my old iPhone 4 got an
iPad Mini right there and I actually
have a [ __ ] audio amplifier yes it's
pronounced [ __ ] look it up but it's for
amplifying your music if you're gonna
listen through headphones which I have
the audio technica ath em 50 seer and
with the long cord I can listen to music
from all the way over here on the
complete other side of the room I got my
oxygen 61 keyboard here and that's all
set up to FL Studio 11 I got my project
2.0 2.0 ops here and it's all connected
together so I can mess around out here
all that nice stuff so that's my that's
my hey guys this quick overview of my
setup you've got my 17 inch razor blade
pro laptop a small system for testing in
my main desktop is a custom build with
16 gigabytes of RAM core i7 in Asus GTX
680 with 324 inch Dell monitors but I
think the most unique thing about my
setup is my Nass running on a dell
poweredge are 510 server it is 22
terabytes of usable storage from 8 4
terabyte drives all connected over my
gigabit network
this is my setup which it speakers in
computer case black live team triple
screen monitors rain meadow
rain Linda roof rules wireless phone
charger stuff that lights up and glows
under UV light and this the infinity
mirror dude I built this hello this is
not the annual piece of ink and this is
my setup so to start I for Nexus 7 2012
and a custom Lego whole second I have a
pair of ways of crackin pros and another
custom like a holder then I have an HP
computer and an ankle gaming mouse
thanks for watching hello everyone
my setup is in the three window coupe
Allah I use a 42 inch Westinghouse TV as
a monitor from my computer my DVD player
and my we here are my remotes my
keyboard a mouse and my headphones I use
a pair of Bost 301 series three direct
reflecting speakers and a pair of
phillips 5.1 surround sound speakers for
my audio powering those are a technics
sadx 930 with a technics 5 disc CD
changer down bottom and a realistic 10
band eq box up top I can set aside my
desk for whenever I want to sit on the
couch and watch TV I'm recording all
this with a Canon EOS Rebel t3i I hope
you enjoyed watching and have a nice day
it's mainly a music production setup
starting with my two mini controllers
which are on the Akai MPK 32 and the
native instruments maschine mikro
coming over to my laptop it's an old
Acer Aspire 50/50 which goes into a 20
inch LG display while the audio is
running through a behringer xenyx 502
mix
which then goes to a pile pearl 3000
watt hybrid preamp hello this is my
setup so video I have two white 32 inch
televisions as my monitors it was
difficult to find them and I had to
scour the internet but I did find it
there from a company called high tech er
and they'll just hooked up to a Mac Mini
which is in my jaw obviously would have
cooled and paid to make sure that it's
not a lot of heat
of course the remote which would turn on
both televisions puts the magic mouse
trackpad solar keyboard
white printer chair and of course just
iPad air and that is my home
7 thank you alright guys what's up this
is my setup tour I'm gonna start off
with my yamaha motif XS 8 keyboard then
on to my rocket 8 studio monitors here
is my homemade headphone horror out of
wood I just stained it and put some foam
pads in the bottom but it's really
convenient you know hold your headphones
this is my favorite part
it's my hackintosh that I built that's
running with 10.9 Mavericks so yeah
thanks for watching
welcome to Sweden this is my room and
this is my setup a 40 inch TV and the 22
inch monitor over here we got an Xbox
with it it's an ansi sticker if I touch
it with my phone and expert smart
clothes will start immediately this
video is taken by a Nokia Lumia 920 and
over here is my share this is my
Logitech I navigate through Windows 8
with it and my tablets and more NFC
stickers I use em 50 years all the time
I just recently did a lot of cable
management on my system in the corner of
my living room here and I'm actually
really pleased with how it's finally
turned out it's kind of where I wanted
it to be everything's really nice clean
all the cable runs are nice it's really
minimalist but fully featured so I've
got everything as much as possible off
of the actual surface of the desk to
give it just a bigger feels
an out rigged shelf for my computer the
mics on a stand the monitors are both on
stands and I've got that nice 10 kilos
keyboard that I love and I'm really
happy with this setup
hello mkbhd fans this was set up first
off we have a comfortable chair a MIDI
keyboard Samsung Galaxy Nexus - or
wanted monitors one of which you can
turn so you can watch it from Tibet a
Wacom tablet a laptop a robot holding a
schedule and a scanner printer printer
device
hello mkbhd viewers this is my super
quick setup tour so over here is my
13-inch MacBook Pro 24-inch monitor
Galaxy Nexus fifth generation iPod Touch
Apple Bluetooth keyboard Magic Mouse
Magic Trackpad by far the most unique
feature of my setup is that all my audio
is air played using this airport express
to this Bose Wave music system - thanks
for watching
[Music]
[Music]
now finally we have my favorite category
this is for the pixel lovers it's pretty
easy to tell why these setups were
chosen it's because the person using it
is probably a pretty big fan of having a
lot of pixels in front of them at all
times
like me see guys Harry's were set up
over 2013 I am at a 2013 MacBook Pro
Retina a 3 LG IPS monitors I raised a
keyboard a mouse a I phone 5s which you
actually hear iPad Mini 2 a blue Yeti
microphone I can 608 which I'm recording
this with an Xbox 360 Xbox one and
obviously when you get thirsty when
you're working in your gaming I've got a
mini-fridge under the desk hi guys
what's up this is my thirty second mini
set up tour and here you can see my desk
with the three 27-inch Apple displays
connected to my brand new Mac Pro and if
I look to the right you can see my
custom-made and backlit Genius Bar
look-alike board my printer and some
other gadgets let's check out the left
side of my room
there is my black rack containing the
networked gear the two redundant servers
and a ton of disk space what's up guys
my name is Jake Hilborn
and this is my entry to the 2014 set of
tour I'm running Arch Linux on a quad
monitor desktop this workstation is
navigated by my kvt pure mechanical
keyboard with cherry MX blue switches
and it's powered by a custom built rig
the most interesting part of my setup is
that all four monitors ardi bezel you
can see the internals are exposed
circuit boards and all ID bezel the
monitors since it reduces the gaps
between the screens which is important
when spanning videos across multiple
monitors typically I use my desktop for
programming and web browsing if I feel
like booting up Windows and I can deal
with all the Microsoft style crashes
then gaming is great too
thanks for checking out my setup hey
guys it's Jimmy from pyrogen gaming here
as you can see I've got two 18 inch
monitors a 24 inch in the middle it's
just a box standard Microsoft keyboard
which I plan on upgrading soon and a
razor abscess mirror mouse the one
unordinary feature about my setup is the
lighting I'm using a strip of light
switch LEDs and it comes
it's a very very cheap solution which
works extremely well for the price tag I
recommend you check it out if you are
into LED lighting but that's about it
guys thank you for watching see you guys
later
you
hi guys this is my setup video for mkbhd
setup total project 2014 my men set up
is 327 inch monitors running from an a
guitar
inside we have an Intel i7 4770k sits 16
gigs of ram and duo 760 I don't have
enough time to explain everything but
all the components of the setup will be
in the description for the project
there's an Epson with a 720p resolution
and the white screen is 84 inches thank
you
so this is my setup it currently
contains a late 2012 MacBook Pro Retina
one Mac Mini 6 additional external
displays 2 iPads and several external
storage devices in addition to the 6
other displays there is also 6 Philips
hue light bulbs overhead which allows me
to change the color of my setup to any
color I would like through my iPad one
thing that makes my setup particularly
special is it features a 27 inch
touchscreen display and that is my setup
and a full review will come later
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is a quick tour of my setup one of
the things that I'm gonna put an
emphasis on in this video is my desk the
sheer size of this thing allows for tons
of screen real estate to exist as well
as having plenty of room for other
activities stepbrothers reference for
things like a secondary computer or even
workspace for a laptop or some
old-school paperwork my main computer is
a core i7 hackintosh tower and my second
computer is a little core i3 machine
also a hackintosh on a test bench I also
have various processor boxes and Doc
Brown's famous time machine as geeky
decorations thanks for watching my quick
setup tour and I'm glad I could be a
part of the project
hello mkbhd years welcome to my setup I
run three monitors for productivity as
well as three peripherals but the star
of the show is definitely audio with my
xenix mixer the audio technica ath m50
headphones a blue spark microphone as
well as my blue snowball all aid in
Assissi mean getting top-notch audio and
of course you can't forget these little
guys
thanks for watching hey guys Michael
over five three four here and I'm doing
a quick desk setup tour as you see you
see my three monitors I indeed do use
all three and you can see on my gaming
gear it's all Razer I in doodied love
Razer and you can see my computer this
computer is custom built I have built it
by myself and pretty much yeah I just
love it to death so yeah see you later
[Music]
hey guys I'm Liam and this is my setup
video for mkbhd as you can see I'm
rocking 324 inch AZ's monitors to rich
that run through that PC that I built
that dual boots both OS X and Windows 7
my ATM 50 headphones a wooden hippo from
Zambia that my friend got me a Microsoft
Sidewinder keyboard a gigabyte Mouse an
Xbox 360 and ps3 that run through an
HDMI switcher to that azuz 24 inch
monitor a keyboard a blue snowball a
nexus 7 and a MacBook Air thank you guys
for watching
[Music]
[Music]
hi guys Matti droid one two nine here
today I'm gonna be showing you my desk
layout so let's go I have my 27-inch
iMac they're followed by my note 3 on
wireless charger with the note 2 and
iPhone 4s on top of my wireless HP
printer I have my I heard I with a red
smart cover um I have my macro Pro here
15 inch retina with fire 2 gigabytes
flash storage lots pixels and I love it
I've got my down laptop running Windows
8 here of my external monitor my iPad
4th generation on my beats pros thanks
for watching hope you liked my video
here is my submission to mkbhd x' to
start you can see my triple monitor
setup with the wall mount you can see
those two umbrellas those are my night
lights then we have two custom-built
hackintosh pro 2 Apple keyboards Magic
Mouse and Logitech trackball there's the
pebble - a very unique feature to my
setup is the desk underneath the table
this allows me to roll out the bottom
desk and do something with it I guess
and then to wrap up we have the blue
spark microphone what's going on guys as
you can see I like pixels so I have 3 24
inch 1080p monitors on my desk and over
to the left of my desk I have an Xbox
360 a blue Yeti audio technica ath M 50s
a Black Widow keyboard and a rat 9 and
of course down below my custom built PC
there's powering all three monitors and
even though I have tech I do like to
keep it analog so I keep a pen and paper
and my setup at all times and of course
my docks the most important part of my
setup hi guys I'm recipe from cake
sentry and this is my setup for early
2014 that I hope you'll enjoy
[Music]
so this is myself 12 video will show you
my I have my gaming PC verse with three
23-inch one is yeah it's costing look
there's my 2011 by Mac connected to my
MacBook Pro Retina I'm just gonna do a
quick super close so there's my gaming
PC my iMac and Mac report this is what
looks at together
[Music]
[Music]
I'm zurka and one and this is my setup
so basically I like pixels as well and I
have here my beretta MacBook Pro 15 inch
now which is 2880 by 1800 and my I have
a turtle monitor here 1080p and another
with 1080p all connected across so this
is all together around 8 million pixels
of course this isn't the 4k displays
that you have a PhD but this is my setup
so here I have computer I have an
external hard drive I have a thunderbolt
Express dock I have my headphones and my
favorite part of this set up my audio
technica at2020 microphone with a blue
icicle interface so yeah this is my
setup I hope you liked it right I'm
gonna get right into it
we're gonna stir on the left here I have
the 76 10 HP Officejet wide format of a
first generation iPad Mini with the
OtterBox and an Apple wireless keep Mac
Pro xeon quad core and that's hooked up
to these three
two-twenty most monitors only about beer
to this guy this is he
technical Pro rx 130 mm watt amp and
that's connected to these two speakers
behind and have these guys right here
which is connected to the Mac Mini hey
guys my name is Alex and here you see my
setup I weigh the monitor stand and
lighted every single post LED stripes
I'm healed in three 27-inch Samson
monitors and the custom-built PC I'm
very proud of my movie collection I left
her the skills to the University and
studies with all the stores all my
movies in year an Xbox an iPad for
gaming
hey guys computer Lascaux here first
video this is going to be my set up tour
for 2014 now you can see the bottom
monitors here are 1080p monitors these
are connected to my gaming computer
which is entirely water-cooled now the
top monitor is actually running 2k or
2560 by 1440 this monitor is plugged
into my Mac Pro desktop now one of the
unique things about my setup is that I
have a piece of software called synergy
which lets me use both systems with one
mouse and keyboard very seamlessly this
allows me to keep my desk looking less
cluttered then out here do another
office tour since last time we did an
office tour I put a new couch I love
some artwork got a new another monitor
in place still have oh there's a laptop
there now still have the iMac MacBook
Pro and there's a Mac Pro on the floor
and still have the custom desk that my
father built and cleaned up a lot of the
wires that people were complaining about
on my last tour thanks a lot so this is
my setup going from right to left we
have my TV my top spec 15 inch MacBook
Pro with my iPad right above it and my
AOC 23 inch monitor with a ps3 under
that okay one thing I kind of think is
unique about my setup is this shiatsu
massage pillow I purchased off Amazon
for about 40 bucks it provides great
back support I also really really love
my screen setup it really works for me
I am Christine and welcome to my 2014
set
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to my store on the left I have
an iMac running Mavericks with a second
monitor on the right I have a PC running
Windows 8.1 with dual monitors my custom
PC is built inside a mac pro case I am
running an i7 2616 gigabytes of memory
and a GTX 670 I control the Mac and PC
through one mouse and keyboard with a
piece of software called synergy
essentially giving me control over to
os's and four monitors what's up guys
here's my cell surround by my customers
not done yet but when I'm finished gonna
be a beast
my first generation iPad Mini macbook
mouse 3 monitors webcam speaker speaker
iPad air 16 gigabyte and my iPhone 5s
and all me sits here but I'm recording
on it gaming keyboard gaming mouse and
this pretty much my workspace and my
chair so the guys has been myself - hey
guys this is my room tour as you can see
I have three monitors which took a while
to save up for my favorite part about my
room is probably my custom-built
hackintosh which I built last December
it features a quad core i7 had 4 point 5
gigahertz so that is my room guys thanks
for watching
[Music]
hey guys my name is Mike and this is a
quick look at my custom test build the
interesting thing about this desk is
that it's built entirely out of closet
doors I repurposed three high-gloss
white closet doors from Ikea to build a
desktop and monitor housing I used a few
four inch aluminum legs for the shelf
and a four by eight sheet of melamine to
make the desks packing cutting a small
two inch wide strip that runs the length
of the desk so I could drop all my
cables through finally I added some LEDs
for lighting and mounted some power
strips under the desktop for charging
all my devices
what is up everybody just wanted to give
a quick set up tour for the mkbhd
project here you have three 24-inch LG
monitors the highlight of my video is
the fact that this stand for these
monitors is actually a do-it-yourself
homemade stand so as you can see it's
not that pretty from behind but I did
make this entirely by myself out of
maybe thirty dollars worth of parts here
we have a Windows 8 eight side as well
and here we have a 50 inch smart TV to
complete the set up door thank you for
watching everyone this is my setup the
2014 three displays and the computer I
built myself it's a core i5 3 gigahertz
with 8 gig of onboard memory and in the
Vidia g4 650 extreme graphics card one
gigabyte I built that early 2014 that's
my setup thanks guys what is up guys i'm
kb HD here and this is the final video
of the set up to our project 2014 and i
guess it's just a quick sneak preview of
probably the messiest my setup will ever
be kind of in the midst of the end of a
pretty tough semester at school so
clearly stuffs got to be cluttered but
thank you for watching this whole
project video again my full setup tour
video is going to be uploaded very soon
probably after i clean stuff out and
reorganize for a couple of new things
i'm adding to my setup but that's
basically it so thank you guys for
watching I appreciate the support much
more content coming I know there was a
bit of a pause but it's back talk to you
guys in the next one peace